it's mag a month ladies and gentlemen it
is officially manga month
i'm disappointed in all of those who
have not changed their profile pictures
to american flags i did it first thing
in the morning and i had to yell at jack
posobik
you know so you have
yes i'm sitting there uh um i'm doing my
podcast right i'm up at like like
crack at six in the morning actually i'm
up at like five because the one-year-old
you know had something going on so we
had to be up for him i'm doing my
podcast then i'm hosting war room
pandemic for bannon because he was out
today
and i get done that and suddenly i find
out that i hate america
so you know
jack tweeted something
and then i noticed your profile picture
didn't have an american flag in it and
it was like 10 a.m or something so i was
just like
conform conform
get that american flag in there so i
tweeted jack hates america which i've
always had it on my profile like name
right it's always been there so come on
all right so it's there now it's mag a
month
it's going to be a month of uh grilling
grill as often as you can
during mega month we make america great
again that means it's all about building
community it's about cleaning up our
neighborhoods picking up trash it's
about shaking hands and hugging your
neighbor it's about love it's about
freedom it's about saying no to racism
and that means if you don't like maga
month you're a racist obviously that's
the only way to explain it so anyone who
criticizes manga month well they're
racist it's the only way to explain it
because the the the core of making
america great again is to embrace the
love so that's what it's all about but
we got news we'll talk about news it is
the friday before the fourth of july
weekend so i imagine many people are
probably just
not watching podcasts live on friday
night as they you know usually don't but
uh we're we're chilling we're gonna have
a good time
we gotta talk about more than one in
four americans say it may soon be
necessary to take up arms against the us
government so that's kind of freaky
we'll talk about that cnn's ratings have
imploded at the same time daily wires
ratings are through the roof and they're
signing more and more people i just i
just i really love saying that over and
over again that cnn plus collapsed and
daily wires exploding because that's
that's good it's like the right thing is
happening it is um
it's a good day how about that so we'll
talk about that we also got jordan
peterson's
nuclear response to twitter saying he'd
rather die than take down his tweet and
he also made an interesting point i
talked about this earlier
he was talking about the fat chick on
sports illustrated and you know because
he was like this is not beautiful
and then he made a point about confused
kids
and then i realized something i'm like
if you're if if orientation is not uh
learned but it's ingrained and then you
have a little kid and you show the
little kid a trans woman and you show
the little kid a fat woman and the kid
says i'm not attracted to either of
these women and then they go oh you must
be gay like these are kind of things
that are confusing to kids because you
know if they have an attraction towards
a specific thing they're told they're
transphobic or they're fat phobic and
all that stuff it's probably confusing
them so we'll talk about all that stuff
my friends before we get started head
over to timcast.com become a member to
help support our work as a member you
get access to our exclusive segments
from this show monday through thursday
at 11 p.m not so family-friendly it's
the tim cast irl after hours and you're
supporting our expansion we've got a
couple uh documentaries in the
preliminary stages we're of course
working on a bunch of music
we're of course expanding cast castle we
are hiring more personalities we are
doing more and uh hopefully
one day soon we will be where the daily
wire is but congrats to those guys they
are certainly setting a standard that we
all should be striving for and in
growing and dominating culture and and
winning so with your support we will
continue to do that so don't forget to
smash the like button subscribe to this
channel and of course you already
noticed jack pasobic's here i'm here i'm
here
supporting magamonth where uh not only
do i have the american flag in my
profile superimposed on my face now i've
got my turning point usa usa branded
t-shirt here with me and somebody
mentioned to me that i actually haven't
been here since we got back so we were
in davos you know where they don't
celebrate mega month uh getting
getting detained at the world economic
forum and uh we were working on a whole
documentary about that which will be
coming out soon oh nice
right on we also got shane cashman
what's up i'm here and ian's going to
tattoo an american flag on my face right
now we're live on live during the show
yeah right but uh no i'm really excited
because we're releasing the first
episode of tales from the inverted world
tonight i have spent the last six months
in georgia like a giant slimy eyeball
observing witches and ghosts and
skeletons just time traveling and uh
tonight's the first night and we'll have
a book next month so i'm looking forward
to it that'll be on that'll be live
right after the show well you know how i
feel about cults i will not be bowing to
your mag occult i won't put it i won't i
will not you're getting tattooed next
i'm not putting the flag on my profile i
feel like it's dangling right now it's
america in front of
them's racists
but here's here's the thing i said if
you hate mega month you're racist and
then you know ian admits he just doesn't
come out he's johnny right up on this
one did you guys hear so they're turning
cern back on we talked about this before
the show four mega month right here four
mega months yeah uh july 5th
we'll see i was over there and i said
guys come on let's let's you know let's
kick the tires around a little bit you
drove over cern or thereabout in the
area so we were driving right at one
point when we were shooting the thing we
were driving between davos and and
geneva so you know yes we would have
easily i believe because it's so large
right we would have driven over it at
one point so i want to know if smashing
atoms together is causing the
fluctuation of the vibrational
background higgs field and i can't tell
you everything that tonya and i did
while we were in oh okay while we were
in europe
you know i just got to say
they turned on the large hadron collider
right before trump won
didn't do it in 2020. they're doing it
now
donald trump made a phone call and he
was like i need to win turn it on they
do you need the energy quantum
fluctuations and they're like charging
it off because it's it's basically like
his thanos
fluctuations right the greatest
when ian said that he's not celebrating
a month the whole chat just turned to
ones
rest assured i will be celebrating i
just won't do it the way you want me to
do it there you go get used to it one of
us one of us
all right i'm also here also in the
corner pushing buttons i'm very excited
for this evening we're gonna have a
great night it's gonna be super low-key
and chill thank you guys for tuning in i
don't expect many people to but we're
glad to have you take a look at this
story from timcast.com more than one in
four americans say it may soon be
necessary to take up arms against the us
government and actually a plurality of
of strong republicans said it
yeah that's kind of freaky
the poll was released on june 30th at
the university of chicago's chicago's
institute of politics according to their
findings 28 of voters including 37
percent who have guns in their homes
agree it may be necessary at some point
soon for citizens to take up arms
against the government the funny thing
is
i i bet that stat stays true for like
strong republicans forever like no
matter what because they say it all the
time so i don't know if there's actually
like an increase in the number for all i
know it's gone down right
it felt that way watching the riots that
everyone was trying to take down the
government i mean like the mayor was
getting baptized in fire out there out
west i forget where that was like they
were all one uh in portland or something
when he was standing outside the fire
like doing oh yeah that was portland
yeah right like yeah it seems like he
wanted that desperately tried to get
back in the building like libyan right
but they were throwing yeah they got him
they got him a week a week after i just
thought it was funny to pull this story
up as like it's maga month you see
ladies and gentlemen this is what manga
month is all about all right we got
people who are losing confidence in the
government
they are scared we need to make america
great again and we need a month to do it
so this is that month every month so
does does the story and i i know i sent
this uh to you guys when i was on my way
in but does it break down in the poll
right left right party distinction any
of that kind of strong gop gop
independent democrat and strong democrat
okay now so where do so where are the
fault lines do you see do you see
independence do you see both sides right
on the extremes what would you say no
but like strong democrats 71 i think say
you don't need to okay but they control
the institution so they're like don't
don't it's their government independent
voters one-third of independent voters
say yes seriously one-third one-third of
independent voters and that's more than
which is more than these than the total
it's more than republicans republicans
are like 28 or 30 or something and then
strong gop is the plurality 45 so
among strong gop 45 i believe it's 45
say you may have to and like 42 say you
don't have to that's the only bracket
where
the you may have to is larger
but conservatives
believe it less than independent voters
well thomas jefferson was pretty clear
you may have to take up arms against the
corrupt government like he said that
blatantly just so you know everyone be
as part of being american you may have
to take up arms at some point if the
government becomes tyrannical he was
very clear about that well and this is
jefferson by the way and this is the
same jefferson by the way who goes over
and sees the beginnings of the french
revolution and is like yeah this is
great let's continue to do this
without you know kind of realizing which
forces exactly were being unleashed and
this is why you have these huge
differences between you know sure both
were armed uprisings against a a central
government right a monarchy but the the
american revolution's character was far
different from the the french revolution
character yeah they there was a a lot of
them to begin with it wasn't just like
robespierre and dantone it was they were
starving too the americans no the french
the french were starving the the monarch
was there on their soil with them so
that was another problem they had to
face but it was the americans were very
organized they also had a lot of outside
help with being the french which then
caused the french revolution to cause
the french to go bankrupt which was why
they were starving it was when the women
came out and they were you know hungry i
think that the french revolution was too
culty it was too much about robespierre
it became about his personality and how
great he was and how he was going to
lead them well it was like savior
salvation it was it was like a two-fold
revolution right you actually had the
period where you had the left and the
right
in the uh what the parliament chamber
whatever this is where we get the the
terms yeah you actually had the radical
there's a revolution and the radicals
and then the moderates are like yelling
at each other and then the moderates get
crushed and the ropes appear like off
with their heads and then they off with
his head you know the whole thing was
just kind of crazy first they blew his
jaw off that's the story they they he
was such a he was in order and he was
known for just talk talk talk talk talk
and then eventually they were like i've
had it they blew his jaw off they laid
him on a table for like three days to
die i'm pretty sure that's how the story
goes did they cut his head off uh after
that they might they might have
guillotined him yeah or they might just
let him bleed out let me find out
yeah robespierre turned on his buddy the
number two guy dantone who then said it
would have been better to have been a
poor farmer than a medal in the politics
of man
and that's what people uh you know it's
funny because we talk about how people
don't want to stand up and it's like
maybe they learned a lesson from the
french revolution
duck and hide the fires will rage and
burn down your home in your life but you
may yet survive
yeah you kind of want to you want to
build something that allows for the
system to change not so much be the
leader and the speaker and the feel good
about yourself because everyone loves
you you know it's not yes i mean we we
so here's the problem the united states
has
a constitution that can be amended
congress is dysfunctional the left has
been trying to use the supreme court as
their way of passing laws because they
can't actually get laws passed not just
trying doing they're doing right long
time they they blame minor minority rule
saying it's not fair that these but they
don't understand california used to be
very sparsely populated so change
happens
the problem is right now instead of
being like okay we all agree to work by
these rules they're just saying like
screw it burn it down it's not fair
you'll see more typically
like it's
i get what you're saying right and you
see this in
um actually the supreme court ruling
that just came out on the remaining
mexico policy right where kavanaugh
kavanaugh right uh caved on that but it
was sort of this this idea that
well that was a trump
era policy and even though we all
disagree with it
um
we want to keep it in place for the
integrity of the system because that's
that that was the you know the election
um biden's in now
and you know he does he have the ability
as the current president to rescind an
executive order and the rule that he
does right so you'll see what i'm trying
to say i'm not necessarily trying to get
into that issue whether or not i agree
with that i'm just saying that was the
thinking and so you'll see that more
with conservatives saying we want to
keep the system so that everybody gets a
fair shake even if it doesn't benefit
our side whereas the left will say nah
man just burn it down yeah quite
literally you know peaceful peaceful
fires it's gonna get mostly peaceful out
mostly peaceful it's gonna get mostly
peaceful out there yeah man
you look at what's going out the roe v
wade stuff you look at bill maher came
out and he uh no no i'm starting out
bill maher jon stewart and he said that
uh this is the f is the fox news of
supreme courts and then i'm just i'm
watching that i'm like
why because they're like these are the
rules the country was was set upon
the attitude of these people like jon
stewart
is
if enough people want it it doesn't
matter what the law is and i'm like
that's stupid because people often want
really dumb dangerous things so we have
a process by which we come to cooperate
and agree upon things and if you can't
do it well too bad
the problem is congress is dysfunctional
and so people aren't getting what they
want so they're just they prefer to burn
it down
politicians knowing that you can get
votes from really dumb people are
pandering to them and it's working which
by the way it's it's it's the amazing
thing on the roe v wade um ruling which
for 50 years stood as see that that
literally was the opposite of right
quote unquote democracy right because
they went to the courts and said we
don't like that these republicans are
banning this thing that we want so we
want you to make it a federal not just
law right that would you pass through
congress but a federal rule essentially
ruling that there's a right to this that
doesn't actually you know appear
anywhere in the constitution but we're
going to protect it as if it does so
that these states can't decide on their
own how they want to run their states so
it's it's this really weird kind of
situation where they banned banning it
right they banned banning abortion
that's what roe v wade
did and so overturning it doesn't allow
abortion bans it allows each state it
didn't even
it said you can't ban it in the first
trimester in the second trimester we'll
have a conversation that's correct and
the third can be banned
and
you ask these people they don't even
know what roe did or what casey did
casey changed from a viability standard
from the from from trimaster to
viability right but they don't even know
why they're protesting i was watching
this one video where this woman is being
interviewed she's like an antifa person
and she's like real roe v wade or
whatever and she's like i should be able
to go down and the government should pay
for my abortion
and then the person's asking is like
you're in california that's how it is
you can literally do that and she's like
everyone should and they're like yes but
everyone in california can do that
you don't live in texas
most of the protests were in states
where abortion will probably continue to
be right overturning roe was the most
pro-choice decision because it just gave
it to the states whoever you want right
right yeah most of
choice yeah right actually increasing
right now they just want republicans to
abort their babies i got mixed feelings
about it because people say like i don't
want the government involved in in
medical procedures and then so the the
supreme court said okay no governments
can be involved in this medical
procedure it's completely up so then
they're like no no federal government
yeah no federal government
and now
now there's 50 governments that can
decide so like before there was one
government deciding the union now
there's 50. so is that better
i don't get this the states all had laws
on the books
they
so
rowe basically said
the the question with rowan casey is
does the baby have its own privacy
rights and the general idea was at
viability it does previability it
doesn't because it's dependent
and so states were allowed to pass laws
restricting or regulating abortion and
they all did so you had 51 governments
this the federal government just said it
is not up to the cons the supreme court
said we do not have authority on this
congress will have to pass a law we out
and now one less government was making
an imposition and the 50 states that
were in in some way regulating just
changed the way they were regulating so
they're all still involved plus it's
like it even goes down to the county and
state level city level too like it's not
just one government it's thousands of
governments regulating all this stuff
i've definitely got abortion fatigue at
this point the conversation has gone on
like maybe because we're on a talk show
and it comes up almost every day but
it's it's it's like
it's because
in my opinion the democrats are using it
for a very serious wedge issue
they're protesting
i don't understand what they're
protesting and and to your point ian the
fatigue what do they want what are they
asking for california doesn't need
anything from texas new york doesn't
need anything from oklahoma the people
who live in those places for the most
part voted for these policies and these
politicians
is it that the majority of new york is
is looking out for the eight percent of
oklahoma that is concerned about this it
looks like two separate realities are at
war and they're def like because it
comes down to just one reality thinks
it's a life and the other doesn't and
like they're warring over the definition
of life or they think it is a life and
they're willing to kill it or yeah or
just i don't know man human sacrifice i
think i think you're sort of right but i
don't think the left has any real
cohesive standard by what they're
talking about yeah because
look some woman today she posted how is
it that abortion got banned as i saw
this meme on facebook how is it these
abortion abort abortion got banned
before an assault rifle
and so i just responded with assault
rifles are banned under the hughes
amendment 1984 i believe 1984. and um
you can get them the grandfather den
you're referring to standard
semi-automatic rifles and she's
responded with i'm referring to anything
that can kill a kid and leave them like
a bloody mess and i'm like okay well
that's all guns
anything that can kill a kid right it
could be a brick right so if you've got
kids but believe me like that's that
crowbar you're as a parent you are
constantly in a state of just when
you're around your kid you're not all
right this can do this this can do that
they could fall they could do this thing
they could they're they could turn out
any door they can literally turn
anything in their home into that yeah my
my views act as 86 is that right is it a
firearm owner's protection act okay
right so i was wrong
um but my point is just like
if if you post something incorrect
and i say i understand what you're what
you're saying let me give you the proper
frame and you say i don't care i'm like
okay i get it you don't care like you're
literally arguing nothing
fine
then what's the point of a conversation
with someone who's arguing nothing i
don't do it i won't do it but this is
the this is the this is the the rule it
is the exception on the right is the
rule in the left
and it's the exception on the right and
the rule on the left what is the
exception
that on the right you will encounter
periodically individuals who don't
actually argue for something they're
tribalist but it's the exception the old
the the actual ultra maga like fringe
trump diehards who believe crazy things
like come march 3rd donald trump will be
it's like okay there's not very many of
them they're not prominent in media
there's there there are some politicians
that that have pushed closer to the
fringe of that but the mainstream
conversation defined as the right for
the most part is like extremely
argumentative extremely nuanced like
look at the show we did on the roe v way
over roe v wade over turn day with with
sheamus and austin peterson and will
chamberlain we all disagree i was
listening to that show live and that was
fantastic that was a fantastic episode
but this is the quote unquote right and
it's like it's funny when people on
twitter are like tim's right right wing
and i'm just like i i lean i'm center
left on like a lot of public policy
issues i'm just libertarian
if that's the case then what we call the
left with nancy pelosi democrats they're
not arguing for anything they're not
arguing anything it is
the rule
on the left they will not give you an
argument it's the exception some of them
will
on the right it is the rule you will get
the argument it's the exception
sometimes it's tribalism it's kind of
like emotions versus logic i think a lot
of people that would consider themselves
leftists are driven by their emotional
standards but i think i think there's
another angle to it as well that that
gets into the word rule itself but it
like in in the other sense of the word
rule as power right and so i think that
for 50 years roe v wade stood as a
sacred cow for the left for a very long
time it was one of the most powerful
things that they think of it right they
were able to impose by sheer force of
will right this is the this was the
culmination of the radical 60s the
sexual revolution obviously that they
were allowed to put past this not just
in their own states they willed an
actual amendment to the constitution
into being through the courts without
actually having to go through the
constitutional process itself
and
it stood the test of time for 50 years
and so i think that they realize
inherently um and even you know even the
folks like pelosi and hillary who are
around at that time they realize that
that level of power that they've had is
starting to slip away adrian curry
chatted tim is super left with sprinkles
of right that proves it that that does
prove it yeah but are they rainbow
sprinkles
yeah
oh my oh no this is the funny thing this
one through
people were commenting like
tim poole's is far right this proves it
mug a month and all that it's like
it's it's very clearly meant to be just
a silly fun thing to do that's not you
can't have fun you can't have fun how
dare you
we say that now on the show but
afterwards the ritual will commence
right the robes come with the margarita
yeah it's called the fourth of july yeah
right
it's just it's yeah we're going to grill
things up fireworks no i think i think
you've got to blow stuff up for i think
civic is a holiday 100 i think civic
rituals are important i think a i think
a functioning society a cohesive society
has civic rituals and you know fourth of
july obviously is is one of the largest
ones but it's it's so you know even even
the more you know basic ones like you
know standing up for the national anthem
at a baseball game or there's there's a
drive-in movie theater i take my kids
too and they play the national anthem
and they say hey can everyone just get
out of your car and like they don't say
it's like shut up for like it's a minute
right but you stand up and you do that
and it is a natural it is a national
ritual what should happen
is that at every sporting event a large
glass holographic screen comes up with
hulk hogan playing the electric guitar
with the american flag behind him and
then fireworks start launching like
crazy agreed while we all sing in the
national level we all ride eagles into
the sunset that's right i want to i want
i want to pull up this uh tweet because
it's friday we're gonna have some fun i
have this tweet uh from shuon head
everybody i i'm i'm sure you know shawn
wait wait wait this this this tweet it
could potentially be considered violence
now tim are we good to show this yeah
this it actually is very dangerous
alexandria ocasio-cortez called for
violence but we're reporting on her call
for violence and we are denouncing and
we are absolutely denouncing no no
for the sake of clarity
aoc in a video said that people should
be you know i'm not going to say it no
aoc was asking people to send emails and
phones you're going to do it i know you
got to be yeah because youtube's crazy
right aoc speaking of video was like
everybody call your reps call their
offices send them messages and post
cards but she didn't quite say there is
a phrase that is
i'm going to play it there flood their
phone i'm going to play what you said
you guys ready
let me i always got him i always got to
fix the audio because
we were we were playing something here
we go you ready you ready
and we need to be really blowing up our
elected officials offices
says loud and clear queen
it's a funny thing
is lefty she's like left libertarian and
so many lefties got really mad that she
posted this why they were like it's out
of context obviously well duh that's
yeah joke it's literally we know what
aoc means aoc is saying call your local
reps standing back and standing by
standing back and standing
here's why i bring this up
not in any way to drag aoc i mean
there's a lot of things to criticize her
for i i just we the video the video clip
from this show
when she went on colbert and just made
up stuff we called aoc we called like
what was it aoc pulse chad move yes
by blatantly lying on tv lying on live
sheamus was right he was like
do you know what happened with this no i
didn't see this aoc went on colbert and
he was like what should the president do
in response to row and she goes well
we're informed by history you know uh
looked at the civil war
the confederacy had taken over the
supreme court and were ruling in ways
that was impeding abraham lincoln like
dred scott that's that ruled black
people couldn't be citizens so what did
abraham lincoln do he signed the
emancipation proclamation and when i
watched that happen i was like banging
my head on the table because it's just
like a hodgepodge it's actually kind of
the worst
it's actually kind of amazing
yeah it's kind of chad it's it's sort of
like
it it reminds me of like the you know
the sort of like like the secret
president theory and some of the
different things like it's it's wait if
you don't like like right if you don't
like your own version like if you don't
like reality it's not your life you're
liking you just make up your own oh yeah
but but but with this one it was kind of
just like i'm imagining a dude sitting
back and being like abraham lincoln his
cousin winston churchill oh
so let me just for the sake of just for
the sake of breaking this down because i
have to do it
too i i know you guys may have seen this
segment we did on it but i want to
advance i want to talk about media
that's what we're talking about here
with the story but uh just to clarify
dr uh the confederacy did not take over
the supreme court maybe she means they
were more sympathetic to the self fine
dred scott was four years before abraham
lincoln became president so no the
supreme court was not impeding him the
confederacy had already seceded before
abraham lincoln was even president the
emancipation proclamation was signed two
years after he became president six
years after dred scott and in no way had
anything to do with dred scott by the
way in the middle of the war right right
right and it wasn't until the end of the
war and the 14th and 15th amendment that
citizenship was granted to slaves so she
she just made everything up but anyway i
digress aoc i need to brush up on your
juneteenth history seriously i agree i
am not bringing up this clip of her
saying you know blowing up offices or
whatever to drag her i'm doing to make a
point about the media right because this
is what they do
the fact that aoc said it and we know
the intent of what she said modern media
doesn't give that benefit to anyone
associated with the right no at all ever
donald trump could come out and be like
he'll be like did you see this video of
aoc saying blowing up offices now we
know she met we know what she meant and
then they'll say donald trump pushes
idea that you should
you know blow up offices or something
like that
and then they've done this to me where
they're like there are these things go
around you and i are both on these
things where they claim that we are
pushing election election misinformation
stuff
what do we do
there's a bunch of these studies where
it's like you know tim
oh the studies right right right they
never they never quite explained what it
is that you said they just said no they
just decide that you said them and then
they they put you on the list
here's what they do here's what they do
i'll give you an example shane
tell me
that uh
the sky is not green
sky is not green oh shane cashman pushes
idea about skye actually being green
promoting the theory that sky is
potentially green that's right it's true
by bringing it up and saying anything
about it you've pushed it and you say
like you promote can you say shane
cashman quote the sky is dot dot dot
green they do that
that's the point about what aoc said
it's technically a functional way to
question someone you guys ready for this
one what is deception we got another
clip she won ahead says she
all right you need to listen to this you
ready
supremacy is a fact
it's not just a fact
you look at
fbi statistics
no white supremacy is uh okay
yeah that's that's what they show hold
on hold on
that's that's that's it i got there i
got a legitimate question though jamie
pull off the fbi statistics yeah in what
actual context is she saying these
things because um why is she telling
people to pull up the fbi stance that's
interesting
i think it's be no there actually is
there is an fbi
uh report that will come out talk and
talking about um
white identity extremists and or racial
identity extremists or whatever the
latest term is for it and they will
find all these things like somebody
committed suicide but then they'll
consider that a homicide or you know
something is tangentially involved and
they will call it a a white terrorist
attack and they will use this to create
this like hugely inflated number out
there which is coming out from the fbi
saying that um that this is the greatest
threat to america today let me let me
break this down
there ben and jerry's pushed this racist
idea
uh
the issue is the left and the right will
cite the same stat in the fbi to make
the opposite claims right
the stat posted by ben jerry's
that
you know the black population is 13 of
the united states yet incarceration
rates among the black population is way
higher which is quite literally the
exact same argument made by white
supremacists so when aoc comes out and
says white supremacy is is a fact
it sounds like out of context she's
saying it is real like it it is it is a
true thing like like she's promoting she
believes they're right right right
and then when she mentions fbi stats
what she said
could could be slightly altered and come
right out of the mouth of a white
supremacist oh yeah you're right
it's it's it's it's the exact argument
because they project everything
well because the the woke editorial left
the critical race theorists are outright
right racist so they look at everything
and they're like that's the only
explanation and they're making the same
argument the difference is who they
think is the racist person aoc's
argument is oh this proves the police
are racist because these people
shouldn't be in jail whereas white
supremacists are like it proves bad
things about black people when in
reality they're looking at the same stat
asserting some racialized ideology and
just making everything worse for
everybody thanks aoc but there's also
there's also an element of what um
michael anton at claremont has has
written about this and he calls it the
celebration parallax where he says
if the
if the left cites something
then we have to say oh it's happening
and it's and it's good and it's
wonderful that this is happening but if
the right identifies the same
uh
pattern or trend in society it's it's a
conspiracy and it's wrong and it's
probably racist to even talk about it
right so you and you can say this about
the great reset is a great example of
this right you know where you can we're
where they'll come out and say or even
with the the thing that was uh going out
today the liberal world order if you
went on twitter today and typed in
liberal world order you would think oh
it's going to play that clip of brian
deese who is the white house economic
advisor
when they ask him the question you know
why are americans paying f 4.85 uh cents
a gallon going into you know fourth of
july weekend he says well it's for you
know i'm paraphrasing
we have to protect the liberal award
order and people are said oh well at
least he's honest right you know um guy
but comes from blackrock by the way and
if you went to twitter
and searched that uh earlier today i
don't know if it's still there and so
if you if you search it today right now
it's still there it's all up yeah that
if you search it there was a fact check
that was the first thing that you saw
and it said fact check
comments today about liberal world order
are not the same as the conspiracy
theory that a new world order is being
instituted by
the united states government that is not
up anymore now it's it goes right to the
new york post article new york post
probably just helped to dispense with it
and your stuff actually it was there at
my stomach tweeted the video right wow
you know and there was a fact because
before we can even let you engage with
the content that was again stated by
the white house economic advisor
regarding why your gas prices are so
high right they had to correctly
frame it for you like i left this meme
before you can even interact with the
actual well let's pull the story up here
i've got it here from the new york post
biden advisor liberal world order
demands enduring high gas prices i just
want to point out first and foremost
they said
that it was going to be a quick thing
the gas prices were going up now they're
saying it's going to be years yeah so uh
okay sounds like that's just the case
they're saying until ukraine wins and
they might not and if russia wins then
your gas price is just going to stay up
forever but here's the best part about
this liberal world order thing it's not
a conspiracy theory anymore now like you
said just a moment ago they're arguing
it's not the same thing as the
conspiracy theory yo
there was a time
not even that long ago couple like
decade ago if you said the the gulf of
tonkin incident was a false flag you
were a conspiracy theorist and i think
it was the 2000s when they finally came
out with reports being like actually the
u.s kind of staged the whole thing so we
could enter vietnam it's like okay
in my lifetime i have watched the
narrative break down and start crumbling
and
i mean kind of hilariously alex jones
being proven right more and more often
although he does say rather crazy
outlandish things
he ends up talking about things epstein
that was a conspiracy theory
gay lane maxwell was sentenced to 20
years for aiding the trafficking with
epstein
powerful global elites were flying on
his plane not a conspiracy theory
anymore the the line on that i thought
that was the best and ted cruz actually
posted it ted cruz beam right it was uh
galen maxwell the first person to be
convicted of trafficking children to no
one exactly but there was a period where
if you brought that up that there were
powerful global elites trafficking
children they were like oh here we go
right they still try and claim the idea
as a conspiracy and if and if you well i
mean it was a conspiracy but a a fake
one like made up if you come out now but
not absent that's soon
no that wasn't big that was real i'm
saying they claim it's not real right oh
yeah like so here's my point epstein was
conspiring with other people there was
traffic women there was a period
where you know probably only several
years ago if you claimed there was a
powerful global elite
with world leaders flying on planes and
they were trafficking they called you a
conspiracy theorist then epstein it all
comes out elaine maxwell gets sentenced
that scene
is shuffled loose the mortal coil as it
were
now it's just like oh yeah we knew they
were doing that now the crazy thing is
there was a story i saw and it said you
know like 50 of republicans believe
global elites are running child
trafficking rings and it was like
incredulous and i'm like what what's
wrong with the other 50
no no but but right but the issue is
it's like they're trying to make it seem
like it's a crazy idea to have when
elaine maxwell was literally on trial at
that point let me show you this other
story take a look at this one
i just i saw this in the morning and and
you know look i normally i like the
daily mail they're not that bad they're
not like the best
clarence thomas cites debunked claim
that coveted vaccines are created with
cells of aborted children in descent on
skoda's decision there is so much wrong
with this story
okay
they go on to say
clarence thomas suggested covet vaccines
are developed using cells of aborted
children
underneath that sentence it says
cells obtained from elective abortions
decades ago were used in testing during
the covet vaccine development process
what how can you have these two
sentences next to each other they're
stupid
i read the headline here's the best part
you're right you don't read you only
read the headline you don't know the
facts let's say you actually got to the
second part you're like oh clarence
thomas was right
no
clarence thomas didn't actually cite
this at all
clarence thomas thomas
referenced the plaintiff argument
in his descent
he did not say personally i clarence
thomas believe that this vaccine is
developed with he said the plaintiffs
are suing because the vaccines x y and z
and then the media went oh he's saying
it's true too and it's like no no he was
citing their arguments which is exactly
what shu just did to aoc that's right
the exact same thing here's the best
part
the vaccines are developed
using cells from aborted babies for the
testing process we wouldn't call that
the best part but the difference right
i mean i mean i don't know the
facetious best part yeah the media is
the fact that they said it's a debunked
claim
no it isn't this here says that that
they were created with the cells but
you're saying they were tested on it
with the cells but then it did the final
product of them too because there's the
which is
possible
but hold on we'll get as literal as
possible
in the process of creating this vaccine
there are numerous steps now that's a
good argument the creation is the entire
process of development which requires
testing before any kind of so if you're
just talking about the final thing that
they end up making maybe all the things
they tested aren't being used in the
final things now that's a challenging
not only did he never say the words
created with he said development and he
was citing he was quoting a group they
attribute it to him they changed the
word in the framing and it's fake anyway
because
how could you create a medication
without testing it how would you know it
did anything if you didn't test it you
know you should ask
you're not listen you're not legally
allowed to do that
imagine you were like this person is
sick i'm going to take a chemical the
chemical is medicine for it i've never
tested it but i'm just going to sell it
now no no there's a testing process in
the creation of any drug so even if you
want to get technical clarence thomas
would have been right should he have
actually claimed it was created using
these things it is just such a mishmash
garbage nonsense media landscape anyway
my point is to go back to the liberal
world order stuff
today
if if you talked about new world order
even a month ago they were like it's a
conspiracy it's not real and then you
got who was it who came out i mean joe
biden said it several times he said so
biden has said it and we were playing
the clip earlier today where he was this
is 2017 he uses the exact same phrase
liberal world order and so you you've
heard also a phrase a lot lately the
rules-based world order but when you
hear this again liberal world order and
you realize that okay this is really
it's it's
defined world by the way because it
doesn't seem like most of the world is
in this did you see build back better
all over the place
all over everywhere
but you look at the countries that are
involved with the bank for international
settlements which is the swiss bank
governs like the federal reserve and all
these other federal these banks you see
the countries that are stuck inside of
this liberal economic order it's the
same what i'm saying is you see like
maybe maybe japan south korea but it's
not it's not all of asia it's certainly
not all of africa um there are huge
swaths of south america that aren't part
of this thing and so when it comes down
to it you know if you can define can we
get a map of the liberal world order you
know can we get you know do we have
flags for it uh
here's what they do have a month for it
there will be someone who says
lizard people
and then they'll find the craziest claim
and say this is what the new world order
conspiracy theory believes
then you'll get a major politician like
biden saying it's time we get a new
world order and what he's saying is we
have a liberal world order and we need a
new kind of world order which means
powerful global elites and interests are
colluding for the sake of international
governance which is literally what the
council on foreign relations calls it
and then if you say oh did you see that
they're talking about new world order
and look
that means you believe in lizard people
try to debunk it before the internet it
was easy to do because the media would
just lie right now we can talk to each
other much more easily and they can't do
anything about it however i checked the
wikipedia for the
uh liberal economic order the
liberal rules-based order the u.s led
world economy basically and they have
wikipedia has changed the wikipedia uh
in the last month maybe even damage
control for when this guy came out and
said it they took away the from when you
go to the wayback machine and look at
the difference it's pretty stark in the
beginning of this they were very overt
that it was a u.s led world risk
economic border
yeah let's go back into let's find out
when they recently changed it because
they took the u.s led part out of it
because you know people are hitting it
they're reading the first paragraph and
they're toning out
but this is very much that after world
war ii they decided we don't want
another world war we're going to use the
u.s and the u.s military to set up
military bases all across the world uh
use opec we're going to use the american
military mike to force people to buy oil
and u.s dollars create a global currency
create a global authority that's
basically what this uh world order is
now there's also a world of thought that
um that it's actually sort of an
inheritance of the british empire
that where you know and maybe even 500
years from now
when
you know whatever america is at that
point or whatever you know north america
is at that point um that we may that
historians in the future may may even
just consider
this order as a continuation of the
british empire may not even separate
them which really was like the banking
empire that got into july by the way
like hey check it out check it out just
real quick sorry again no problem
the first article is the liberal
international economic order and then it
actually references the new
international economic order so it's
like so it's the liberal world order the
new world order the remix yeah
i think what happened was when the
rothschild family in like the 1700s
started their banking empire this
bavarian banker his three sons uh split
up and each took a piece of of the
banking empire basically that's how they
got it started one of the bankers went
to england and that guy started
controlling england through the bank and
uh that's the new world order is the
banking part of it right what so when
you're saying it's an extension of the
british empire the american empire which
is really an extension of the banking
empire this bavarian banking empire now
they're set up in switzerland uh with
this bank for international settlements
which needs way more media attention
we're gonna have to not a conspiracy
theory anymore gentlemen
the the narratives busted apart and it
was easy when someone would
you could be a researcher and you can go
hey new york times did you notice that
there's a bunch of documents showing
that there's a bunch of international
elites coming together for some kind of
global economic order and they'll say
don't know don't care we won't publish
it now you can actually publish
documents and there's no denying it
just breaks through through the barriers
your name is julian assange there's the
song well he did a lot more than that i
was told like the un was basically all
the countries of the world the best
powers of the world then i found out
about the non-aligned movement you guys
familiar with the non-aligned movement
it's every other country that's not in
the u.n it's basically another u.n it's
the other one like there's two worlds
going on right now i mean one of them is
the u.s led rules-based economy and then
there's everything else the there's the
g7 and there's bricks and bricks has i
think what like four or five times no
like six or seven times as many people
and that's gross bricks is growing so um
this is one of the biggest things that
we've seen this week and and really
nobody is talking about it that which it
and it is and i'm just gonna just gonna
say it right this is growing as a
response to the liberal world order
slipping and and collapsing in upon
itself um you can look at potentially
the turnover of hong kong as one of the
early you know kind of precursors of
this and then really though just what
two years so today right xi jinping went
to hong kong for the first time since
the protests in 2019 and those protests
were over okay so hong kong yeah they
changed flags in 97 that's when when the
uk formally rescinded sovereignty but it
was 2019 when they passed what they
called the national security law where
the ccp essentially came in and just
just took essential total control just
total control and xi jinping today this
very day visited for the first time and
he said hong kong has risen from the
ashes wow that's what he stated today
because he knows he's one so let's talk
about the limits so and so no no but my
point that brix is a rising bricks is on
the way up iran just stated that they
put in a submission to join bricks i
don't know if they've changed the
acronym then um and do people know what
bricks is argentina's talking about it
um so brexit what is it brazil
russia
india
china south africa right five of the
world's biggest countries and certainly
population wise and they are raising a
started starting military but excuse me
starting economic but they're talking
they're talking military certainly china
russia
and they're moving to ian's point in a
currency basis as well i'm wondering
about the liberal economic order and the
value of it because i i trash it a lot
the whole idea of a global military
economic government is that's in the
shadows is terrifying but the reason it
was built was to prevent a world war now
if we completely just dispense with it
it's gone tomorrow you've got bricks
you've got like an autocratic communist
government so is it it's like is it do
you believe it's one or the other jack
like what i'm interested in your take on
the liberal economic or the value of it
well so this is me the right this gets
to me as as a populist you know and what
i believe is that i think that we do
need to go back to a system where
and this is where the phrase america
first comes from right
so people get the mistake that america
first means american only or that
america should just go and do do
whatever they feel like and that no
that's not necessarily true it's just
that our government should exist for the
benefit of the people who live within
the confines of the country right um
which is the opposite obviously of what
brian d said today and so it is it is in
the benefit obviously of the united
states to have military alliances to
have trade to have economic relations
but we shouldn't put those global
organizations and transnational
organizations ahead of the interest of
our own people we need to go back to
what you know might even be considered
more of a of a 19th century type of
formulation in this idea of sure we can
have these these forums that exist right
you can call it whatever you want you
know but we should never become
subservient to them it should always be
a forum which is subservient to the
sovereignty of the nation itself i feel
like a lot of people are begging for
that kind of world though yeah right now
it's scary like when i was in new york
people were they really wanted a big
government across the whole world to
keep them safe
from covet and we just and that's the
opposite of what we've seen and that's
and that's the by the way and that's the
great reset right that's that's what the
great reset is that's what the
documentary we're working on is about
that's apparently why i got detained in
davos for you know having the the
audacity to to simply go there and talk
about it we also went to geneva and
talked about the world health
organizations pandemic treaty that
they're trying to push on the 104 to 94
nations and so this is the problem right
the problem is that you have for example
uh i just mentioned hong kong right so
when we were in davos um
we were going up and down the promenade
we went through a huge so russia's been
kicked out right ukraine everywhere
everything's ukraine ukraine flags
ukraine house underwritten by victor
pinchuk who's victor pinchuk by the way
he was the oligarch who at one point was
one of the top donors to the clinton
foundation right it's one of the most
powerful oligarchs within uh within the
ukraine sphere um russia's been kicked
out ukraine's everywhere and we're told
you have to support ukraine because you
support democracy we also we went to
ukraine as well and um
we went down to odessa mikolai my
brother was with me and
the one thing though the one word that i
didn't hear anywhere
at the world economic forum in davos
there was no house for it there was no
speaker who mentioned it there was no
breakout session on it and that was the
word taiwan
the word taiwan was
completely omitted from the world
economic forum and so my question was
was you guys care some you know so much
about democracy and freedom
where's taiwan on this and it's simple
because the ccp has set up a situation
where they're in this military slash
economic alliance with russia and the
brics nations but they're also in an
economic relationship with the west and
the liberal world order because why
because we've been financing them with
western capital since the 1970s
essentially since the death of mao and
the rise of
deng xiaoping
and
post um you know post tiananmen square
it was it was the bush family and it was
uh so many interests associated there to
say essentially look we're not going to
push over the power of the ccp we're
going to make a deal with you and
snowcroft goes over there and has the
secret meeting right because the ccp
could have been on their last legs if we
just pulled the rug out from under him
and cut fdi immediately on june 5th 1989
but that's not what bush did when he was
in office he said we're going to make a
deal we're going to make a deal with you
our manufacturing is going to come over
here we're going to use your slave labor
that's where that's going to go we keep
the ip
right so we get to maintain
the companies we get to maintain the
power and the profits from it you guys
get all the manufacturing and that's
been the bulwark of this liberal world
order because we've outsourced our
manufacturing to asia we've outsourced
our energy to the middle east as it was
and this was something that trump when
he was in office was whether he meant to
or not right
that was what he was working to roll
back that's what gave us american energy
not just independence but dominance and
that was why he was so opposed to nafta
tpp so many of these deals well let's
let's get serious about what's going on
in the world though you talk about all
these very scary things let's talk about
the source of their power
the large hadron collider inverse
reports the large hadron collider
restarts next week here's what it's
hunting for also right now
by the way also right there yep it is
but i got i want to point something out
i am kidding i think it's going to be
fun that they restart this but there's a
lot of jokey
silly theories about they're not silly
all right all right but hold on you're
going to love this one but you know
geneva that really is like the global
head oh for sure people think it's the
u.n but like geneva really is
like that's that's the main engine of
the united states
let's first say this yeah the large
hadron collider in geneva is restarting
next week a lot of people think weird
stuff is going on we have this story
from august 18th 2016. humans from this
is from the independent you can see
their little pride symbol next in their
logo even though it's maga month what
are they doing human sacrifice staged at
cern home of the god particle cern says
the ritual could undermine the actual
science that goes on at the organization
now here now they say a human sacrifice
has been staged in the grounds of the
european organization for nuclear
research the home of the god particle a
video circulating online shows hooded
figures apparently engaging in a ritual
staged under a huge statue of a hindu
deity at the end of which a woman is
stabbed but the footage appears to have
been recorded as part of a prank by
scientists then you get this on
wikipedia the cern ritual hoax
okay far be it from me to claim it was
anything other than a prank but it
reminds me of uh have you are you guys
watching the boys
i know it i haven't seen it it's the new
show on on amazon prime and i'm not
going to spoil it but there's a point at
which two characters are arguing and
then one character turns out to be
recording so the other character goes
you're not supposed to record when we're
running lines
and i thought that was hilarious because
like that's a way out of getting caught
so someone's filming you like oh we're
just we it was we were acting the whole
time
and then i see this and it's like
someone posts video footage showing a
human sacrifice and they're like oh it
was a prank this is a prank bro just art
it's a prank just art we just we're just
doing it we got you buddy we got you and
you know you know but it looks like you
stabbed that woman no she's not she's a
prank she's screaming
that's acting so the issue is look
here's something to say
i have no evidence of anything about
what happened with that human sacrifice
thing at cern but i'm not just going to
believe the media when they're like it's
a prank bro i'm like okay well dude i
don't know that doesn't debunk anything
you're just saying it's a prank right
you know interference patterns so if
there's multiple frequencies going on
that aren't the same they interfere with
each other and then you get a
diminishment um and if people are
vibrating
uh and there's too many of them and
their their vibrations are interfering
with each other
that would mean that you need to remove
some of the interference well i think i
think this is good
i'm sorry
i'm talking about producing coherence
you wanna you wanna talk about
conspiracy theories let's talk about
conspiracy theories what is going on all
right check it out so uh there's the
fluoride conspiracy theory that
calcifies your pineal gland or whatever
i don't know what that means um
i guess it does i don't know does it do
anything but the idea is yes it does
i've read scientific data that says the
pineal gland can calcify yeah and so
people often say that that pineal gland
is like the third eye to help you
perceive the spiritual and stuff and by
living in a world where we've
we've neutralized our abilities because
of fluoride we've
essentially destroyed our third eye or
whatever
and so there's that idea then this was a
funny one the double slit experiment
right right you guys know about the
double slit experiment yes
you don't let me explain so uh they if
you take a big sheet of metal
and then you uh behind it you put a big
target board
if you fire off a bunch of shotgun
blasts at that sheet of metal with a
single slit through it
when you go behind it what will you see
on the target board a straight line of
of pellets or you know or buckshot or
whatever from the shotgun so the the
plate shields everything but that slit
if you put two slits what would you
expect to see two straight lines right
behind it
they did this with electrons
through the single slit they got what's
called a uh part a particular a
particulate pad our particle pattern
meaning a straight line of electrons hit
the back sensor when they used two the
double slit they got an interference
pattern suggesting waves
which is more like water
hippies then went on to be like whoa
that proves that the observer changes
reality and it's like well
no it's like the method by which we
measured it changed wave wave function
collapse so it doesn't mean a whole lot
but
a lot of people believe the double slit
experiment proves that the observer
plays a role in when reality collapses
to a single point that is there could be
an infinite number of universes and that
you as an observer observing something
determine when it collapses to a single
position as opposed to a superposition
to oversimplify it again your
observation manipulates reality and
creates it
if that is true then the conspiracy
theory goes there are too many people on
the planet and all of their observations
are interfering with each other creating
a chaotic world which results in a
donald trump presidency so the
conspiracy theory is global elites want
to call as many people as possible not
because of overpopulation but to
diminish the amount of of observers who
are affecting reality
i think it's all magic talk mumbo jumbo
and might as well just be a science
fiction novel but what is happening
through corporate media where they're
giving us a distortion of information
through that it's like every time you
read anything i think what's happening
in the double split you got most of it
right but i think there's something
about it was when they had two slits if
they fired the electrons through and no
one was watching they would come back
later and they'd find two two pattern
two lines but if they record it and i
can't be getting it backwards no no no
no then they find the interference
pattern when the other
when they when they measured
which slit the electrons were going
through they got they went through one
or the other right they got they got a
particle pattern when they didn't
measure it they went through what looked
all both it went through all and created
a wave pattern so that's when they were
like wow the act of measuring which one
it went through changed wave function so
too much observation is creating too too
stagnant of a reality
is the conspiracy theory in reality
there's a much simpler explanation
imagine there is an uh so so i'm sorry
for all the hippies out there who
believe in the double slit experiment
i'm going to debunk it for you uh or not
debunk it but cast doubt because i've
always thought that it would make that
the simpler explanation would be it has
something to do with the function of the
measuring well exactly so yeah
so imagine there is a table and an ant
is walking across the table and you are
like i wonder how far that ant has
walked so you take a ruler and slam it
on the table and then the ant turns left
and you go
the act of observing the ant changed the
direction i can control ants with my
mind and you're like no dude you put a
ruler next to it and it got scared and
ran away
whatever you did to monitor the electron
interfered with its function and changed
what was going to happen that's the
simple answer right a lot of the hippy
dippy people are like it means like when
you look at it with your own eyes it
changes it does indicate that the
observation tool can interfere with
behavior and wondering we are
observation tools are we inadvertently
interfering with reality just by
watching it is that why meditation is so
valuable because you you remove yourself
from the observer but that is not the
point i'm making the point i'm making is
that
when you slam a ruler next to an ant you
create a physical disturbance and the
ant will change its behavior i think the
physical disturbance of the observer is
undetectable it is not the fact that a
human eyeball is looking at a machine
measuring an electron it's that you are
injecting something to the point where
the electron is causing it to physically
interact i bet when you're when you're
thinking about something you're doing
that too
i don't i don't believe it it's i don't
think that but you know far be it for me
i don't know but this is why let's talk
about meditation like i mean twitter i
don't know if you guys feel it but i get
agitated when i get on there not always
sometimes i'm so educated i don't
realize
well i mean that's everyone opens
twitter
psychology have you ever meditated for
like 20 minutes and come out like a
placid lake well it's nice to just get
all the noise out for sure i mean you
have to do it and is it like if we don't
meditate they're gonna they're coming
for you they're coming for your thoughts
what i'm doing is meditating but i'm
trying to stay away from the phone and
turn off the tvs well i don't own a tv
so what is it it's either either they're
going to try and reduce the population
by making us have less kids or we're all
going to start meditating and everyone's
going to change we're all going to go to
the metaverse
so think about this if the observation
thing and the meditations thing is real
that means prayer is real
prayer is for sure real and then
the more people who believe in this and
pray towards it and focus on it the more
real it be prayer seems to have a
function it's like dropping a pebble in
a lake if you pray once and you think
healthy you pray that and then the
pebble drops then you have no thought
and the ripples will go out and things
will become healthy but if you keep
thinking healthy healthy healthy it's
like dropping a lot of pebbles and the
crease interference and you don't get
the effect that you intend didn't they
do a study that found that people who
are prayed for often recovered better or
something like that yep yeah i was
reading i was reading i was i was
actually i was reading some scientific
study a while ago i could be wrong
though but it sounds like you read it i
i don't know the details on me right now
but you know just just
stories like that and studies like that
and then and just just seeing the power
of it in my life seeing the power of it
in
in my career politics um you know
i i undoubtedly right and with
unreservedly believe in the power of
prayer um and i've and i've been
teaching it to my children as just part
we make it part of our daily life you
know we do it before we eat we do it
before we go to bed um we sit we pray
the rosary right that's that's what we
do right
and it's not something where i'm like
you know screaming at them you know you
got that word wrong or something like
you just make it you make it part of
life yeah and it works in the opposite
direction too for doom like in the town
that i've been writing about uh for the
next book
although it's very religious there's a
lot of people who've they're deeply
connected right to the civil war and the
doom has never left this town and like
this yes it's just one thing after
another
it's almost like they're manifesting it
i don't think they are but it's you know
they're they're praying and there's
people there who are deeply religious
but the the younger generation right now
is so filled with doom i mean it's
they're completely hopeless and like
they're it's like the town is
inescapable it seems like a metaphor for
the country at large perhaps for
that age group you know to be scary if
you if you if you search on the internet
you can find sources telling you
anything you want to hear that's pretty
true that's the real challenge that's
fine absolutely i found studies saying
it does help and i found somebody saying
it doesn't help have you guys heard of
dr masaru emoto he did a study human
consciousness on water he he'd focus
prayer on water and then measure the
molecular structure of the water and
you'd see different patterns depending
on the energy he's putting into it
they'd be like no scientific method
prove it do it a million times and then
show that but he'd get different
responses when he would do it right so
it's impossible to prove with the
scientific well i think it disproves it
the site this it
as per the scientific method but that's
not the only form of science it's just
one of the best ones we have right now
if he can't recreate the molecular
structure through thought then he's not
doing anything according to scientific
method he's not but just because but it
does seem to be happening he just can't
but explain it necessarily it doesn't
seem to be happening
if if you if you so
this is a guy he like took water
and then he like prayed on it and he
would focus on a word like anger or pain
and then he would take a look at the
molecular structures and find patterns
emerging but he couldn't recreate any of
the patterns so it's just random noise
for all we know it's just the water hit
other water and then shuffled into a
pattern then he prayed and went i must
have done that it's like well you
couldn't recreate it so you clearly
didn't yeah it's not recreatable that's
the thing about the scientific method
though is it's like recreate it or get
out and sometimes things aren't
recreatable they just happen you know
they call them miracles sometimes in in
the religious sense or um but i think
the scientific method we created it as
it's it's a it's a newer form of science
but it doesn't mean it's gonna be the
final form of science i i think
eventually we'll figure out there's more
to
what's going on than the hard
matter that we that we perceive
donald trump was memed into the
presidency have you guys seen that uh
that doc that that internet history
about meme magic and all the weird stuff
that happened
you know about it have i seen it
did you make it
do not speak to me
about the deep magic i was there which i
was there when it was written when it
was written yo the donald trump
keck conspiracy stuff
it's crazy they summoned a an egyptian
chaos god
right
right which no because people were and
you know because there was a certain
avatar meme that was very popular in
2015 and 2016 of a frog alt-right you
know you know of course right which
which again it had nothing to do with
with
that sort of thing it was just sort of
like
it was it was the idea that and frogs
have generally been associated with with
like chaos right for you know throughout
history and
they're they're just they're okay
they're a chaotic creature ever try to
catch one and so people are looking this
up and apparently the egyptian god of
chaos was actually a frog named cac
named keck here's and this is how crazy
it is right in world of warcraft when
you were playing the opposing faction if
you were playing the alliance you saw
the horde if they typed lol the
translator would turn it into kek so a
meme emerged among young people where
they would say kek instead of lol for
laugh out loud right cac is the egyptian
god of chaos a frog pepe then there was
that uh that album
what was that album with the
chatelaine with and it was a frog it was
italian right all these weird things
started coming together
and then there's a whole bunch of like
4chan posts where it was like someone
said something like if i get trips so
when you post you get a code a string of
a string of numbers and they're like if
i if you get three in a row at the end
something happens and it was like all
sevens or whatever it was like donald
trump becomes president the whole post
was all sevens it legit it's like
probably one of the funnest and funniest
i wouldn't call it a conspiracy theory
but like trippy internet video to watch
that you want to believe is true all
this crazy ian's freaking out you're
making me think of pattern recognition
patterns because i don't think that
we're as free and and wild and chaotic
as we seem as humans or as reality
exists like it it does seem like we're
cycling towards a pat like involved in
some sort of megastructure that we don't
necessarily or that i don't
understand right now
well there's even the um the egyptian
hieroglyphic for keck if i remember
correctly
it it looks like a guy at a computer no
that was fake that was fake that was
fake yeah yeah oh really yes oh no no
they were real hieroglyphics yeah but
they didn't say keck and then so people
put it together because it was funny oh
no way that sucks yeah that's the
reality of a lot of the stuff you think
is my favorite one
i don't think the because it was like a
guy at a computer and then there was
like a symbol in between
and then there was
and then there was and there was the guy
right and they said that the symbol in
between was mean magic happening well
this is why they had to uh get rid of
the social media platforms
because um and i'm saying this as a joke
because people were using them to
effectively pray and mass to cack
egyptian god of chaos and it was working
so the powers that be the big tech
silicon valley people banned them to
stop the praying to keck that's true i'm
kidding
do you see that is the result so is this
why elon hasn't tweeted in
over a week this is the actual actual
keck thing it's it's it is there is a
person sitting there that's pretty close
but it's pretty close to what the other
one was right but the other one had it
would look like it looked more like a
terminal yeah yeah it looked like a
terminal i i don't i don't think anyone
saw it coming i mean i i might even roll
the dice here and say that no one on
earth saw this connection before it
happened saw what the lol would spell
keck which was a frog that they used to
laugh with pepe so it all it sort of
just came together this way and it's
very crazy like in world of warcraft
kaka meant laugh out loud so people
started saying kak instead of life out
loud the pepe meme emerges then people
start discovering that kak is a real
thing there's kakistan you know the kind
of oh i know well i was a mines
moderator at the time
so you're like well here's the home of
the kekistan essentially for probably
about a year the oppressed kakistani
people tim do you think that we are in
like a vibrational
superstruct like in like a
simulation is a vague way of saying but
do you think we're in like a pattern in
a pattern the universe is of course a
pattern everything functions
like math proves the universe is is a
pattern it's a massive one we can't
comprehend the entirety of at least as
far as we can tell but uh if there was
no pattern we'd be chaos there'd be no
order there'd be no structure there'd be
no human body there'd be no stars so of
course there's pattern
and the people if you pay attention you
start to see the pattern but a lot of
people aren't paying attention i noticed
with internet it's like have you have
you talked whenever we talk to people
who do dmt
they're like the machine elves tell you
that i think michael mouse is saying
this that uh reality is like a song yeah
it goes in loops with like here's the
here's the chorus and then here's the
body and then it loops and it's just
like
music being played uh cernovich has been
doing a lot of uh interviews lately
about ayahuasca which is which is simply
sort of like the plant-based version of
dnc
and uh he was on with with alex clark on
spillover talking about this and he did
an interview with charlie kirk about it
and one thing that he said and
that i thought was interesting was
that he said it people say are you
hallucinating he said no it felt like
the hallucination was falling away
like like that place felt more real like
this is where it all started i've heard
that and and
and you realize that the world that we
we perceive as the real world is like
that's the one that is the hallucination
you want you want to hear something
funny to everybody listening i'll tell
you exactly what's gonna happen i know
what the afterlife is you guys ready for
this let's go every single person
watching the show
one day your time will come
and then as you pass
you will see a bright light in front of
you that you will rush through and then
all of a sudden you'll sit up from your
couch and you're ian and you're like
whoa
oh good
we ought to be good for you
ayahuasca is very interesting it's a
combination of a a vine and a root bark
the mimosa root bark and they boil them
together and they boil them again and
then um you drink it and it
your body starts producing dmt
endogenously meaning from the inside you
make your own dmt and then there's
normally your body can inhibit the dmt
so you don't always you're not always
tripping but it has an inhibitor for the
inhibitor well so you consume it what
happens is
the plant has dimethyltryptamine was it
dimethyltryptamine that's dmt dmt in it
but your body will destroy it and it
won't be absorbed when they mix it
they're adding an maoi inhibitor which
bonds to it and allows it to enter your
body and then so it's in the plant and
your body starts producing it in excess
maybe this is what now i've only sipped
on ayahuasca and it was delicious it
tasted like grass like if you ever chew
on grass it's very bitter it was really
concentrated dark brown grass juice and
i sipped on it and immediately felt the
dmt
uh clarity like when i go into chat when
i'm making internet youtube videos or
internet videos and i start channeling
my thoughts and i don't even remember
what i said but that's why i started
recording them in the first place
because i was like i remember it was
cool what i said i just don't remember
what it was how long is the house that's
when you're drinking it uh it was like
for i took a sip and then it was like
within 30 seconds i felt that rush of
clarity and then after about a minute it
was started to dip dip out but i was
just taking a tiny sip wow just just to
clarify i know the surface level stuff
about ayahuasca but just to pull it up
ayahuasca is notorious for its
psychedelic properties produced from the
combination of maois found in
banisteriopsis
copy vine and nn dimethyltryptamine from
psycho
psychotria viridis
basically
it is um
it's a so mao inhibitor is a uh um
what's what's what's what's the word the
i means inhibitor exactly so what
there's a word for when you say atm
machine yeah it's like repetitive yeah
there's a word for that it's called the
monoamine oxidase inhibitor so mao
inhibitors yes and the oil inhibitors
yeah that that at the same time as dmt
allows your body to absorb it that's
what people do i i'm really fascinated
by this dmt is a fascinating subject and
especially with all the weird meme magic
and stuff i don't understand
how an adult human
can't look at the scientific research on
dmt
look at the the history of ayahuasca
and then look at the strange phenomenon
around things like me magic and deja vu
and all of these strange things and not
just conclude there is something
magical to the universe beyond our
conference and the history to um
to put out there i mean this is this is
south american this is the am this is
the amazonians this is peru
uh this is something that that has gone
back
i mean you're there and there are there
are stories that have come out of the
amazon talking about these types of
um
what we would consider hallucinations or
hallucinogens and you know people
essentially state that this was the
shamanistic drink right this is
something that goes back thousands of
years did you guys see the there was a
panther chewing on the vine and then
tripping his balls off it's a video on
youtube really he's rolling around and
looking at the sky it's so awesome wow
yeah
it's not just for humans
joe regan was talking about a couple
years ago i was uh um you know whenever
i talk to people about religion and
stuff i always talk about how they're
just there there are things that seem to
be beyond probability
that it seems so incredibly rare
that it it's it
sure it could happen or that perhaps as
close as you get to a miracle
but the meme magic stuff you can explain
away a whole lot of how did you know
pepe come to be the similar what does it
mean what does it mean where did come
from well someone noticed there was an
egyptian deity which was a frog named
kek and they said hey it's really funny
that we use the frog meme and we say kak
so they make keck the gods some of that
can be explained away but a lot of that
coincidence is just purely chaotic and
magical in some sense i don't mean magic
like a genie blinking and manifesting i
mean just like serendipitous like there
is an ebb and flow to the universe and
things that you'd think are are rare are
less rare than they really are then you
listen to these stories about the
research on dmt how people trip on dmt
but then to share an experience and
you're like there's something else out
there how was it was it they just shared
was it what they shared the experience
or was it that i think the study that i
read was that they had the same
experience um separately no no um
people like uh i'm not gonna name people
but people you've known from the show
like we've talked to have said they were
with each other so they're they they
they take dmt and then pass out on the
couch right and then we're in the same
place
talking with each other that's amazing
yeah something else maybe maybe i'm
sorry no it's all good maybe it's they
fill in the gaps afterwards like they're
you've brain damaged yourself right
memory and then you're like right and
then maybe you go oh man it was like
there's a giraffe there and then i
remember i said you should do a backflip
and then go you did say to do a backflip
we were there together and it's like or
maybe you just did drugs right something
i encountered a lot in the
in georgia in this town was a
coincidence all the time every time i
turn around there was another
coincidence one small one would be like
you know having a general and or
a colonel in the union whose name was
jefferson davis but another one would be
like uh in this town in washington uh
this writer who i i found her book she
wrote like all like the straight
reporting from like the early 1900s
everything was about like the stump has
been removed or this person has died
what not
but one was uh this woman was sick and
it was like 1890 and she traveled 40
miles north and uh that night she woke
from in a fever and had a dream and told
her husband uh that town has burnt down
and she told him the direct path of the
fire
and then the next day this guy came up
on the train and said uh the the town
burned down and then the father went the
husband went down and it was like the
same path and like okay that's that's
weird maybe but like the fact that that
lady had written so much straight
reporting like i'm like that's crazy
there are so many stories like that
throughout human history i wonder a lot
of it can be explained away but every so
often you're like come on i wonder if
it's like pattern recognition like you
see the vibe subconsciously you see the
the wind blowing through the trees and
then that you know deep in your soul
that that means that something is gonna
happen tomorrow like a guy's gonna say
hello to you around 11 o'clock if it's
that or if it's more like we're tapped
into some
external vibration that we are but we're
detached to from it right now i think
because we're not paying attention
enough
and i think i was experiencing so many
coincidences in in this town because i
was hyper aware of the time while i'm
there and doing a ton of research so
every time every day there was some new
weird coincidence whether it was
personal or in my research or whatever
but i think that's because i was like so
uh observant of this one thing and i
think it happens hopefully on a broader
scale for people i really like the
magnetic universe theory you guys study
the electric universe theory at all
thunderbolts project is doing a lot of
good work on it and um it basically
indicates like gravity as we know it is
actually a form of magnetism maybe it's
like um i don't know what they call it
when some a wheel starts to spin so fast
that it looks like it's spinning
backwards right there's a resonant
frequency so you've got like this
resonating frequency of magnetism that
looks like gravity but it works like the
closer you get to earth the faster you
get stuck to it just like a magnet the
closer magnet gets to a magnet the
faster it gets stuck to it and so i
wonder if we're inside of like just this
magnetic field vibrating and so it's all
obviously we're inside the black hole
that cern created in 2008 right yeah
we're still in there yeah sorry the
earth was destroyed we all got sucked in
i'm just imagining it's uh you said 2008
you said or 2016. i thought it was 2008
when it started oh when they started it
yeah but in 2016 they fired it up and
also trump won earlier but yeah they
only fire every few years is it so so is
the is the original timeline still there
somewhere
well
i'm just imagining they're like you know
they're flicking all the switches and
they're like getting ready to fire it up
and then all of a sudden they're like
are we ready all right ten nine and then
all sudden like a gasket blows and like
where where they're like what's going on
the power levels are going through the
roof what do we do shut it down i can't
it's locked in
and then everyone in stern's like no and
then like a wave just ripples across the
universe and then all of a sudden like
donald trump is about to give his
concession speech and then the wave just
hits everyone and then also he goes i'm
the president and everyone's like yeah
and they're clapping and cheering that's
how it happened it feels that way
yep i think we're trapped in it
meanwhile hillary clinton was in like a
protective case like sphere with her
with her uh you know security team and
they're like what just happened and then
they look at the tv and like the
timeline changed and she's like no
no and you know what happened the
russians
planted a device in cern overloading the
power supply to manipulate the timeline
that's that'd be a that'd be a fun movie
wouldn't it yeah i like this the gas
prices are high because of cern you're
saying right right such weird that's why
i always say when um whenever the
simulation is going crazy i'll i'll
tweet this sometimes they're like
like they got they got certain cranked
up again don't they boys yeah
simulations run a little hot right now
you just you just turned it down just a
little bit it's not the only super
collider in the world they've been doing
this for a while like i think they
wanted to do cern here in the beginning
well we have um we have fermilab yeah
yeah smaller my my favorite bit is that
we're in a simulation but it's not like
some grand intelligent being it's just
like some dude in college who's playing
a video game he's like playing you know
simulation earth
and then his like he like puts his drink
down to go to the bathroom and sets the
controller down and then when he comes
back his little brother's playing and he
goes billy what are you doing dude give
me the control oh now donald trump's
president come on i got to fix this i
think for sure we cracked some sort of
code in the simulation when we harnessed
electricity because we're able to listen
to the past now we have like a portal
like this video people are watching it
now
from where we did this before you're
listening to it now but you're listening
to it from whenever you come back and
watch those those like early
early restoration videos that people
have done from like the 18th
march jackson's documentary about world
war one right now
oh man it's such one of the best war
documents but it's it's
the ones that get me though is
it it'll just be someone and you can
tell that it's the first camera first
certainly first video camera that
anyone's ever seen because people are
walking past it in the street and it's
like this is what 1890s paris looked
like and people were walking past the
camera going like what the heck is that
thing why is it here
why are you filming us
and the people have gotten really and um
there's one youtuber that does it and
it's he'll put he'll because they were
they were silent right but he's go he
goes in and puts in like period-specific
sound effects
and it's is one of the most trippy
things that you'll ever see because
you're looking and you know that
everyone in this video is dead right
that's the one thing i always think but
it literally to your point in it's it's
we are looking into a mirror and an
image into the past through electricity
yeah it's a portal portal i i want i've
noticed with internet video i started an
o6 and i started doing the manifestation
thing where i would tell people this
something is real and then if people
would believe it it would start to seem
more real and things started to like
coalesce like
like i would just say
it's gonna something's gonna happen i
mean there's plenty thousands of videos
up of me doing this stuff or a thousand
or something and it was like how am i so
tapped into reality now like before i
felt so helpless like i was an observer
on reality and then i started doing
internet video and i felt like i was
controlling and creating reality no but
but tied this back to what we were
talking about earlier right you know
governments have had this power for a
long time right the gulf of tonkin
incident right you know you go back to
the 1960s and you straight up people
were told right we were attacked america
was attacked and we need to go to war
because this happened and you had people
that fought um
syria not just fought in the war but
also fought serious political battles
based on the and for them they believed
that truth so inherently um you could
say the same thing for the maine the uss
maine in the spanish-american war um
which was even a little bit less
government intervention more they
consider it yellow journalism uh of the
time and and uh hurst and gets into all
that stuff and
multiple what how many wars have been
started because of something like this
and so the question is was this a power
right was this a persuasion power that
was used by governments and in some
cases by media because they've basically
understood that if you just tell that
big enough right you you do for all
intents and purposes make it real dude
it's so crazy to think that all of
history that we know of is just told to
us if the news are fake imagine history
so someone superchatted us saying i
should read about the delayed choice
delayed choice quantum eraser experiment
which is even trippier than the double
slit
i i was reading through it a little bit
i would need to read it several times to
actually start to understand it properly
because of those micropd articles where
it's it's so long it doesn't like you
can't even understand what it's about
well you can it's just you've really got
to break it down and and understand what
a lot of these things mean because it's
they're they're foreign terms in a lot
of senses right but they basically say
this
some have interpreted the result to mean
that the delayed choice to observe or
not observe the path of the idler photon
changes the outcome of an event in the
past
note in particular that an interference
pattern may only be pulled out for
observation after the islands have been
detected
the simple simple version of this as
best i can uh simplify it the double
slit experiment was we did this thing
and we noticed that when we were trying
to measure it we got a particle pattern
when we didn't watch we got a wave
pattern with this one they said the
choice to observe it after the fact
altered the event in the past that's
possible because if you think of a
photon it's a ball it's a sphere but
what and then you think of a light wave
it's a wave where it goes up and then
down and up and i think what's happening
is we're looking at a sideways cut of a
bunch of beads of photons but we're only
seeing the top line above it and then
the bottom line below the next photon so
we're actually seeing like a
two-dimensional view of the photon
that's a string it's like on and if you
wave one of the photons it's waving the
entire string which would be the past
string theory i don't know if that i
don't know much about string theory
that's base that's sort of it
but that's the general idea is that um
or at least that's that's an idea that
when we see a particle where they're
entangled it's actually
the same object we're seeing
that's like imagine it's in our
dimension that goes into the fifth
dimension then it comes back to our
dimension it's one sheet we see the ends
of they both vibrate because you're
dangling at the other dimension it's
being impacted so what you're saying is
that on the there is another end of the
sheet where the berenstein bears still
exist
right yeah i think this one's been
answered actually
uh it was answered because
someone pointed out
there was a a run of berenstein bear
books
or videos that used e-i-n
because they were really low-quality
mass-produced garbage
and so there was no quality control
some people actually got berenstein
bears but there was very few of them
now that it's the future and we've
digitized everything the actual ip being
berenstain bears confused those who got
the the garbage misprint versions
it really is a simple observation like
there was one um
like like the shazam thing where they're
like remember the movie where sinbed was
a genie it's like no you're just
confusing the one where shaquille o'neal
was the genie or whatever like it's very
obvious you're just making a mistake you
know what i mean right
yeah mandela effect would be fun but uh
i'll let's have some fun with this uh so
you guys know what the mandela effect is
right yeah
from that idea people have created uh
this this community about dimensional
jumping
where they believe that if the mandela
effect is real meaning that you can
inadvertently be transported to another
dimension
then you can control transporting
yourself to another dimension
and so what they do is they they say
that you need sensory deprivation to
isolate yourself from the from reality
so that you can go in and then visualize
the reality you want to jump to and if
the reality is close enough to yours you
can enter it
speaking of which also look into that
and then watch the movie everything
everywhere all at once because that
movie was that was good they kind of do
that in fringe too though when they drug
her up and put her in the in the tank
and she goes yeah but that's like in
french there's like two realities yeah
there's no these people believe that
there's an infinite number of realities
and that the idea is
you could only jump to a reality close
to yours because let's say you're uh you
know jack episode
in your reality
a close reality would be you but you
didn't come to tim cast tonight that's a
close enough universe to yours because
the divergence is only an hour away that
if you were to successfully
dimensionally jump you could jump to the
reality where you didn't come see i was
even thinking about something more along
the lines of like
you know let's say
one of your past relationships that was
somebody you broke up with was the one
that that stuck right and so you did get
married to
you know the girl from high school or
and then but they're still together or
is that too far too far right so you
wouldn't be able to jump to a universe
even where you didn't come here today
because
that's a huge split but there could be
something very very simple like you
didn't send that text message or that's
it's like as the as the universe is
diverged from probability it's harder
and harder to leap to the one where a
change didn't happen but there are
people who who genuinely they'll say
like this is crazy stuff they'll post
and read it and they'll be like i've
done it
i jumped from a universe where my
girlfriend was dead and now she's alive
and it's just like come on dude no you
didn't but they'll say things like
i was there and i was looking at the
photo of her remembering what it was
like when she was around and then i
successfully did it and she walked in
the room and i started crying and she
didn't know why and she's here now and
it's like or you're crazy
so coast do you ever listen to coast to
coast am art valve
nevada um i'm sure there's people in the
chat i don't know what i'm talking about
that he used to do some nights where he
would call in
and if you ever worked if he ever worked
nights in like uh the you know late 90s
early 2000s you definitely listen he
just he just dominated late night radio
and it was a lot of paranormal you know
chat but he used to do all right we're
doing the time travelers hour i want all
time travelers to call and they would
call in
they would call it i'm from i'm from you
know 45 years in the future 50 years in
the future and they would be described a
prank you know and well the stephen
hawking did this once he held a um he
held a party for time travelers and then
he sent the invitations out after the
party right yeah so you guys know about
john teeter right
um the old internet conspiracy theory
where you know about it yeah yeah where
uh
i think on luke's on we are change
luke's website everyone's byline is john
teeter
but the idea is that this guy came back
and he was like i'm from the future
here's what happened in my future here's
what i'm doing here in the past
and if the future
if if the universe is
a whole bunch of probabilities and
you're going down one path and multiple
in the multiverse exists and every every
option you have creates a new universe
right then it's entirely possible
someone could come from the future and
be like in my future
you know uh trump jr gets elected
president in 2024 and you're like but
he's not even running and then you're
like well my future was different
because you know and then
2024 could come around and then trump
doesn't even run for office and you're
like then how could that guy have been
from the future that makes no sense well
because in his version of the future it
was different right so that's what john
teeter was saying that by coming to the
past they've already changed the future
in ways they couldn't even imagine so if
what they say happens doesn't happen
it's not their fault like they're
telling you the truth it's like oh
that's very works out well yeah very
convenient for you very convenient it's
possible that people in the future
their behavior is changing our behavior
now
but that we wouldn't know that i'm
really fascinated with this quant the
delayed choice quantum eraser that you
can affect the past because
well for many reasons but i don't think
time isn't real time is like we we
invented it to kind of describe getting
somewhere on on time but ultimately
things are just moving everything's
moving spinning around itself and moving
and like
time exists i don't see why you can't
alter well time exists because entropy
exists
time is your perception of other things
moving
so
i think one simple way to explain it
we exist in four dimensions we can
manipulate three
i think of time kind of like if you were
falling down an endless pit
you can't go back up
it's a spatial dimension we recognize
it's a spatial dimension up and down but
you have no control because gravity is
pulling you straight downwards
you can move around left and right and
and you know up down left and right or i
should say forward backwards left and
right but you can't go up
and that's what time is we're
effectively falling through time however
if you drilled a hole all the way
through the earth minus the core just
got the core out of there and then you
fell down the hole you'd false and you
would accelerate accelerate till you got
to the center then you'd keep falling
and but you start to slow down slow down
slow down you come out the other end and
then you fall back into the hole all the
way super fast
well hold on minus the heat wouldn't
that feel amazing though oh yeah if
you're like falling at terminal velocity
and then you pass the point you become
weightless to the center it ejects you
out the other side and then you go up
become weightless for a second then come
straight back down and just slingshot it
maybe time works like that yeah someone
tells us that's true to build that that
time so here's the thing about it so
you're stuck inside time here's what you
need to understand about time travel
though
the patterns in your brain that have
developed over time make you you
if you were to go um if you were to like
rewind time your brain rewinds along
with time so you need to isolate
yourself from time
which means your your time would have to
keep going forward while all time went
backwards that's probably why
like this like this time travel doesn't
make sense
unless you went into a ship
so the issue of people don't realize a
time travel
when a person gets in a ship and then
presses the button and it transports
back in time
while time is going the other direction
or you're moving through a hole in space
you're moving forward through time while
going the other direction that makes no
sense it would be like saying
it would be like saying falling while
you're jumping you know what i mean
that's probably why i think backwards
time travel makes doesn't exist it
doesn't seem to but the video is like a
form of backwards time travel only that
we're perceiving the past
i think our experience of time is just
different like when they talk about uh
traveling near the speed of light around
the lip of a black hole like your time
up there would you know seem to say the
same but down in earth or wherever you
came from it would it would go along
without you so when you came back you'd
be the same age but they would have
rapidly aged so you're experiencing
times different that's just like stephen
hawking's uh theory of it someone in the
chat made a good point uh what's
actually happening is that as we move
forward through time the past is eaten
by giant testicle-looking monsters
that uh just called the language called
the language
i enjoyed that movie that was fun it was
a great movie yeah gigantic weird walnut
looking things eat everything they eat
the past they eat the past yeah if we
can change the past then we could change
the thoughts of people
before and fix now or at least alter
because they say that life i think that
would be a horrible idea i think you
know what you're looking for
right now i was like
what if you could go back in time and
then warn trump and like here's what you
need to do
i just thought about what would happen
if you did you you
you appear just in the oval office like
in a new you know hold on like and
there's like a black ring of smoke
around you and you stand up and you're
like mr president i'm from the future
this is everything that happens and what
you need to need to do you need to take
these actions excuse me excuse me no i'm
not listen i don't know you i'm doing
what i want you're like no and you get
dragged out then he just does the same
thing he's gonna do it no you know you
know that the banner baron theory right
what is it yeah bannon
that no no that um that bannon is barren
from the future so sent back
to warn trump
about what's going on but he can't
reveal it right because you know that
would you know that would definitely
challenge all of it which also doesn't
work because of baron's um um height at
this point but no but he's pretty tall
isn't he
baron's like six nine now yeah but you
know when you get older you start yeah
well the time travel the dilation effect
obviously scrunches you down compresses
your spine because you're compressing
your molecules no no no the dilithium
crystals yeah baron knew that he would
be exposed as a time traveler right so
he underwent a radical procedure to
alter his appearance because in the
future
baron
is at with the scientists at cern and
they're like we've time travel and then
he looks in the mirror and he goes
i'm steve bannon and so then they're
like we must conform you to how bannon
was supposed to look right right then
they send it back in time you know you
can see the future because the light
that hits your eye is moving faster than
the object so you see it coming before
it gets there like when someone throws a
baseball at you you see it coming that's
why people can anticipate where
something's going to be so in that
moment when someone's about to speak you
sense it before they say it which is why
your feelings alter their behavior you
actually see the past
you see slightly what you see is a
slight delay determine the future by
seeing the past so like when we and it's
easy to understand when you look at uh
outer space and things are thousands of
light years away right we're seeing it
to your point though about you know you
can sense when someone's about to speak
the one that gets me and having um
you know so we've got uh you know i've
got two little kids i've got my wife um
my wife's parents live with us we've got
you know big household right um cass
castle right big household right but
when you walk into a place and you know
that
it's empty right and you know that no
one's home
right you can sense it you can sense
that i am in an empty house right now
because there's something and it's not
just the noise it's not just the you
know it's it's there is a lack right
there is a lack of spirit there is a
lack of of sense and you know that
nobody's around and then i'm the one
who's paranoid and walks room to room to
make sure no one's hiding in there well
yeah
obviously psilocybin really created like
a differential between living and
non-living to me like i see these water
bodies in action and then i see solid
walls and i'm like wow this we we put
this stuff here like a set piece and we
are very different than the set piece
that's for sure but it blends in when
you're not when the psilocybin's not my
system it starts to blend in and i just
see everything you know oh so we got to
go super chats i want to make one point
too because we're talking about time
as we're we're falling through the
dimension of time we can't move and i
was just thinking like you ian you
mentioned what if
when time reaches the apex it becomes
weightless and then once it reaches the
other side it gets pulled back into the
direction and everything rewinds rapidly
and then i was like i'm just thinking or
there's a brick wall and the universe is
just falling yeah that's what i'm
wondering because there's no way to know
if we're all moving the same speed we
wouldn't know it's moving at all one day
we're all just existences
well let's read super chats if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
grill that like button become a member
at
we only need about like 800 and some odd
thousand more members so that we can
beat the daily wire
all right if if 800 000 of you were to
sign up we still wouldn't be beating the
daily wire so uh thanks for your support
though and uh you know good
one day we will be a large company we'll
expand at that point and we're really
excited for what they are doing but uh
we could use you to support as well so
again uh share this with your friends
you can follow us at tim castle on
instagram let's read what you got to say
all right vanessa mccarthy ledesma
says or is that what it says in
reference to yesterday's irl if you made
a two dollar version can you call it tim
buck twos i like that a lot a two dollar
version of what i don't know
uh i think it was your your money oh
that one you have it right in front of
yours the tim ross oh tim rocks that's
right
yeah yeah
oh that's right i mentioned making tim
bucks that's right
all right albie damn says happy moga
month tis the time to kiss hands and
shake babies
exactly that is right
trip i throw my babies up in the air
constantly gotta teach them balance and
all that yeah they can catch themselves
yeah trip sucks says ian is on fire this
week i'm catholic but sheamus makes it
sound crazy
jesus walking on water is not literal he
was showing us we could reach a higher
plane our full potential be better
ascend ps catholic means universal oh
well there you go
i love i love making sense of past
stories that's for sure
john kersten says starting maga month
with my birthday full american flag
outfit with we are changed shirt by the
way pozo not liking cargo shorts is
un-american still love you cargo shorts
are not allowed
cargo shorts um probably the 90s yeah
dude
oversized t-shirt too oh yeah 100 yeah i
had the chain remember the chains oh
yeah yeah yeah that you wore on top of
the t-shirt obviously
yeah all right kyle says tim get someone
on to talk esg and how it's destroying
the economy and forcing corporations to
go woke also graphene is a cult
uh let's get you want to hit up james
lindsay we should have him back on i
mean i mean esg in in general though
it's so why why why we say get woke up
broke but that's actually not right so
um it's it's more of a tease right it's
not a law and so uh with the esg system
and this this is starting to fall apart
and that's why we're seeing the economy
overheating and
the the fakeness of our economy is
coming apart at the seams is that um
it's it's similar to the cantillian
effect which is
this idea that this french economist
came up with in basically the middle
ages right and he realized that when
whenever a new gold mine was discovered
somewhere in the kingdom
that it wasn't the people who lived
around the gold mine or even the people
who discovered the gold mine were the
ones that benefited the ones who
benefited from the new gold or the
influx of new gold into the system were
the ones closest to the throne
and so uh this is the same thing you see
now because with money printing from the
fed which is essentially what it is and
spike was talking about the other day um
that they've taken all the breaks off of
this
and
that that is disintermediated now
through the big money market managers so
your blackrock your blackstone vanguard
state street those corporations they get
the money first right essentially from
the fed and and banks in general they
get it and then the way they dole it out
to other companies is not based on your
shareholder value which company's doing
better it's through this esg system
who's being the locust out there and so
you're getting your fresh injections of
capital through this overheated funny
money because you are meeting your woke
quotient so when netflix puts out a
movie like this or when disney you know
puts um lgbt scenes in light year or
kicks out tim out or uh get to melanie
that's him um then you're you are
increasing your esg score that's why
we're getting this all right raymond g
uh raymond g maga stanley jr says shane
at first i was skeptical about inverted
world then listened to the corpse that
danced in hell's kitchen i loved it
loved them all great stories thank you
we were just talking about the irish mob
uh before we were filming that's that's
the story yeah yeah that story was about
the irish so the irish mob used to so
you know that part of um not to get
super into it but that part of
philadelphia that everybody shows the
videos of that overpass and then you see
like the fentanyl zombies just kind of
like shuffling around under you haven't
seen these videos so it's called
kensington right and just look up
kensington go to image search and you'll
see deals exactly what i'm talking about
so this it's and they go viral every
time they're posted well that area in
philadelphia used to be called the
kensington allegheny intersection so so
it's called k a right that used to be
those streets used to be run by what was
called the k and a gang and that was the
irish mob and you may not have liked the
irish mob's methods or the k a gang's
methods and that's why they got broken
up the same way the five families got
broken up et cetera but i tell you what
those streets were clean when the k mob
uh gang was around yeah so uh tales from
the inverted world the new episode just
went up oh so this uh i think i did it
right yeah should be up so so if those
aren't familiar uh
you went down to georgia looking for
some gold to steal yeah shout out to
clint brantley who's i'm sure he's
watching and harry and tammy they i like
live down there i've i don't think i've
ever written which is changing aliens as
much as as this book has but i've i uh i
saw a ufo i don't know what that was it
was just a ufo but i remember i messaged
him at like freaking i was freaking out
and you know there's a good scene of
that where you see me messaging tim
freaking out probably episode four so
but yeah i go down there looking for the
lost confederate gold this is the town
where the confederacy was dissolved by
jefferson davis
he was on the run after the end of the
war after richmond burnt down and um
the the gold had been lost there's a lot
of different theories about it and i
think i come to a conclusion but i got
derailed by major tv networks and you
know people with uh witches
witches ghosts skeletons threats there's
death threats um someone threatened to
kill you yeah yeah uh well there's two
really oh okay two people threatened to
kill you and uh it was it was the last
six months i spent you know going back
and forth in this town does witchcraft
always involve blood
well there's blood magic the good
witches don't like the blood magic i
don't like blood yeah we observe people
who do blood magic and
you know they were and this is
interesting like i wonder what jack
would think about this but there's
catholic witches christian witches nope
i asked
i asked them i'm like how do you like uh
balance you know that because you're not
supposed to worship another thing
because i you know i walk in first
commandment right there i mean two
witches and one's juggling shark teeth
and the others praying to anubis
and i'm about to walk into a hole to a
graveyard i mean you you get uh uh
santeria is is is similar to this where
it's a mix of sort of like like like
voodoo beliefs and
catholicism you do have mixtures right
but it's it's not catholicism the
catholic witches were mad at the
christian witches
did they have protestant uh which just
meet them no but i mean like the coffee
what i'm saying like did the catholic
did the christian protestant witches
break away from the catholic witches and
there was there was
there was witchy and luther which is 99.
yeah yeah
that's awesome but
uh but no i it's me i spent because it
would be like nine hours of me talking
to like the mayor or the the witches
running a hotel or all these people but
i would you know i spent a lot of time
talking to all these people and um
you know
it i feel changed this is a book i've
always wanted to write not about this
exact topic i didn't know that but i
love civil war i love the paranormal
stuff and um
this town delivered everything so the
book is the book's coming out um in a
couple weeks yeah books the same title
uh book will be uh ghost of the civil
war and that's just volume two oh okay
yeah so like the last book we serialized
and it was just different essays they
were all standalone essays like the
corpse
in hell's kitchen was one thing and then
we did like a simulation story for
another um but this one all takes place
in this town and uh you know i spend the
night or a few nights with this one
family on
their land where they think maybe the
the gold could have been we sneak into
cemeteries looking for gold we got we
were talking about
did you find the gold i can't say that
you would know because the fbi would
come and steal it yeah
because that was happening but you know
you know what we want to do is we want
to make a sort of like uh horror
thriller anthology sort of based off
these books because it would be so legit
it's like the x-files that's great yeah
that's great yeah hunter s thompson
meets the x-files yeah yeah exactly
that's how i felt yeah all right so uh
we'll read some more super chats but
when the book comes out we'll definitely
have shane back on and we'll we'll we'll
be showing it for sure and putting it
everywhere and trying to get you to buy
it
uh let's see we got here
redneck italian 1982 says i wanted to
share i kicked off maga month right
today is my 40th and i'm at the field of
dreams watching my two sons play
america's favorite pastime while
lighting things off and drinking beer
thank you for all you do tim cast i am
glad to hear it but maga month is not
just about american flags and drinking
beer and grilling it's about doing right
by your communities
cleaning things up
inspiring young people maybe maybe
you've got like a big brother big sister
kind of thing where you could find some
some at-risk youth who need some
leadership maybe you got a dirty highway
you could clean up maybe you just want
to put on a grill for your neighbors and
bring people together all of that is
good friendship like right that's right
or even just i i used to call this also
by the way tim i forgot to mention that
um you know because you were so upset
that i didn't have my
my profile picture up earlier with the
flag you know on time right on time
that's right right you know um that
we've got immediately first thing in the
morning
we've got the bandana we've got it out
we're going all we're going hardcore got
the usa shirt but you know i actually we
called this i this was something i was
talking about during the pandemic but i
still i still do i call it local
patriotism right find those businesses
that you know those small businesses
that are independent that are in your
area and just support them right just go
out there and say you know what i i want
this to continue and i i need i want
this more than like another panera bread
right nothing against panera bread but
just this is someone in my community
that's trying to make it work and we're
better if we can if we support those
things and do so obviously while wearing
your american flag what do you think
would happen if i opened a woke
restaurant and then enforced policy
based on woke ideals like if you're
white you have to go to the back of the
line do you think that would be allowed
i mean well technically that would be
illegal right
what if i created like a uh so i would
sue you poc and non-poc seating in my
restaurant yeah also illegal that's so
strange that the woke people do all of
those things right it's funny right it's
it's they've they've brought segregation
back but it's good segregation now so
it's better all right let's read some
more
kyle bigelow says you talk and talk
about reforming governance as though
you've never met michael malus
well i don't agree with michael and
everything i think he's certainly smart
and he's changed my opinions on some
things and uh uh i'm not an anarchist i
think michael isn't he's an anarchist
for sure he wrote the anarchist handbook
and then i i voiced um
uh who was the who is the the the essay
yeah yeah um prep proton prodone there
you go yeah that's funny because he's
like a leftist anarchist
so michael thought i guess he thought
it'd be funny if he had me he was like
i'm gonna get the best chapters to be
read by like the people that it's
funniest to like do or something like
that i mean or it's just it really is a
great book of essays that you should you
should check out michael's a very very
smart guy oh brilliant i don't agree
with everything on
all right let's see
nathan tankers uh tankersley
tim poole for 2024 president now we're
talking no
did you imagine dude so so i will say
this i was ragging on um was it shelley
moore capito yes the republican senator
from west virginia who signed the gun
control stuff oh yeah yeah yeah and
she's just a nasty awful person and i
will not forget what she did but i'd
someone be like why don't you run
against her and then i was like that
will literally never happen and they're
like you know you'll win right and i'm
like i will never go anywhere near near
seat of government yeah we got a new way
then you'd have to be a senator for six
years
i mean theoretically i could run win
and then resign
just like well then the governor
appoints right so you don't have
anything you have any say if you resign
that would just be terrible yeah but you
could make a deal
right you could make a deal with the
governor i don't know if you're allowed
to actually do that
isn't that what as long as it's going to
know as long as it's not yeah
not a monetary deal i'm saying that you
know you know you need to support this
to be fair if you're a senator you could
do nothing
any of them do nothing you know no
that's just all this energy
[Laughter]
as opposed to what just don't do
anything yeah lobbyist
which which lobbyist donated the most of
the campaign all right yeah with that
that's a good point because if your
campaign was i will literally do nothing
that's better than what we got now do
you think that they don't listen to each
other is that the problem that they're
all trying to talk they don't listen to
the people
so the reason shelly more capital signed
the gun control bills because she's not
up for re-election for for what five
years
four four five four years i think so she
doesn't care
her consultants probably said listen in
four years everyone's gonna forget this
happened no one's gonna remember it then
you can come out and throw some red
media republicans and they'll vote for
you again and she was like they are dumb
pieces of crap aren't they gun control
what a piece of garbage i can't stand
these people i would imagine that's
exactly what she did too i'm i'm i'm
annoyed and yeah i can i think you're
right she talks like that i think it
would be to be in congress would be
really boring because you'd have to
listen to everyone gets their time to
talk but when they talk they decide to
read something and then they're like not
really charismatic so you're like oh
i gotta do this so do you wonder why
then it is that a certain type is
attracted to that as opposed to somebody
who may actually have more talent or
more interest in the actual you know
running the policies of running our
country right so there is a certain type
that totally understands right how much
what the job entails and craves it more
than anything else that's who's in our
senate that's who's in her house all
right let's read some more jonathan
arnold says tim is correct on the double
slit experiment i'm a professor of
physics yes my opinion on the double
slit experiment actually comes from more
than one physics professor because i
remember watching the movie what the
bleep do we know oh i saw that yeah and
it's it's a bunch of new age you know
mumbo jumbo where where the guys like
the double slit experiment dr quantum
yeah dr quantum and then i was like whoa
and then i went to actually some
universities i was hanging out i was
like in la and this physical professor
physics guy was like let me explain for
you why this is mumbo jumbo oh that
makes sense like i get it but i like the
observer interfering with the process
that's an interesting concept well right
the point is it's our it's the process
by which we observe causes the
interference it's not it's not profound
it's like
slapping the table with a ruler and the
ant runs the other direction i notice
that when people are talking if i don't
look and i it's a different conversation
as soon as i look at one of the people
the conversation gets like jarred and
yanked into some new form that's because
of how you look well that's true too
track media only says if prayer worked
then donald trump would be president i
disagree
the first time he won you're the power
of meme magic people were going online
and they were all laughing and joking
and there's a simple answer to the me
magic stuff tons of people were having a
laugh it was a party it was a joke it's
like you could join the fun just post a
trump meme
that's effective messaging
they didn't have it second time around
so or the more magical is that everybody
was so hyper focused
they manifested
president trump
all right
john shaw says i'm 21 years old we are
not doomed at least not myself and my
peers we're very stoic and optimistic we
desire and commit to authenticity i
believe there's so much to look forward
to just look at dw and tim cast more to
come
that's right the daily wire gained 300
000 subscribers in like three months
yo that's nuts
that's crazy
glad to hear this good sign jordan
peterson jordan peterson's going ham
right now on twitter he's like i'd
rather die than delete my tweets
he i i watched that video he posted
where he addressed it like a 14-minute
talk yeah he was going hard he's in him
he got angry really he was like ah
i was just like yeah
good for him dr peterson things change
and grow like laterally now maybe they
always did somewhat but i used to think
things would grow horse or vertically
like a company would get would get
bigger and bigger and bigger but now
things get bigger but they also get
wider faster because the internet
variability let's go
all right
it is now now it says love you tim but
you were so wrong in the double slit oh
someone said i was right look up the
delayed choice double slit it has such
immense implications about our reality
it's mind-blowing look into tom
campbell's book my big toe
well all right i'll check it out
um i love that stuff man i i when i was
younger i would back before youtube well
youtube was around but there was google
video
oh yeah yeah i would go on google video
and look up physics
and just watch physics processors talk
about the craziest stuff and that's what
i would watch before going to bed that
was back in the day man it was fun i
watched
youtube video high that was what i would
[Laughter]
some of it was just like awkwardly
boring but then like it's it's you'd
think it would be boring where it's like
a guy like well when you have to
understand what the with the the edge of
the event horizon and i'm watching and
i'm like what and then within minutes
i'm like whoa
i think that person said the delayed
choice uh double slit what they meant
was the delay choice quantum eraser
because i can't find delayed choice
double slit
all right caslin bucart says jack i'm
pro-life but i'm concerned uh over the
overwhelming amount of misinformation
around roe especially with ectopic
pregnancies and miscarriages how do we
as pro-lifers health influence the
change of culture around abortion
i mean it's it's gonna you have to do
the work right you just have to do the
work right obviously there's we there is
a sea of misinformation on this topic in
general uh people talk about it in
emotional terms but you know i think
what
even the the comment just before when
they were talking about authenticity it
just breaks some of this down right with
with some of these pregnancies you know
the the number one reason that people
get abortions is is elective right now
number one by far right and so do not
allow something that is one percent or
two percent or less than one percent of
uh of outcomes to dictate our policies
justin allen says my first super chat
ever canceled hulu disney espn hbo and
subscribed to tim cast and daily wire
the episode with stephen marsh was one
of our was one of my one of favorites
says i always share your videos keep it
the good work really really do
appreciate it yeah so one of the
challenges we have right now is like
obviously our flagship program for tim
cast is literally tim cast irl the
members only videos are somewhat topical
and relevant to the time period in which
they are talked about because it's
politics
many of them aren't what we want to do
and one thing i've been thinking about
and um i'm going to be talking to shane
about because we have talked about doing
the conspiracy talk show so we have pop
culture crisis which is pop culture it's
similar format to this
what i want um
is we could probably do this we need to
talk about it but a similar talk format
show you've got your deep investigations
where you like go down to georgia we're
planning the next book already
but
how could we do a a show that's
evergreen talking about mysteries
conspiracies aliens ghosts psyops
governments and all this stuff something
that people could watch
forever yeah you know and so that's
that's what i want to do because because
i know you were working on it before
yeah it's just balancing all these
things make it difficult yeah it'll be
great we had a good i mean ian was on
the members only for inverted world we
got into some of that stuff and chris
carr our great editor who's been
hustling on on me sending this book to
him um
we we went pretty darn pretty hard on
conspiracy theories in life yeah i mean
maybe they totally do that maybe this is
just what we need to figure out we need
to figure out maybe if it's once or
twice a week you doing like an hour talk
show with a couple people similar to
this
so we have inverted world the
front-facing show which is the book and
the podcast which is your investigations
and then the members only stuff like the
streaming video on demand show is the
conversations around all the crazy stuff
there's enough out there to talk about
yeah they keep coming true so
let's do it
that'll be fun
all right
m sheba says in the anime simpha gear
they have the concept that those stories
and myths being told throughout
the centuries whether they were true or
not could will them into being reality
well that's fun i just finished watching
attack on titan season four that's a fun
show as well
gotta love it attack on titan's legit if
you're interested in the culture war
have you seen it i've talked to us
before
it's it's um it's a weird show
like gigantic naked monster people
eating other people didn't they do a
live-action one that's stupid yeah it
was really dumb though okay but the
anime it's actually really simple there
was a meme where like an ai jordan
peterson said to watch it but if you're
interested in the culture war one of the
big big themes about it is the sins of
the past a group of people who are
condemned because they were oppressors
and so everyone's like you're the evil
oppressor and you have to atone for your
ancestors and that's like a big theme of
the show oh wow so it's like
right very culture war-esque there you
go you know except people are flying
around with like shooting cables and
then slicing monsters and turning into
them and stuff i was doing that earlier
yeah the odm gear uh jack uses it and he
swings to the trees to make it here
all right lone wolf 36s says something
to chew on if we are inside the wake of
a black hole it would appear to us the
universe is expanding but really it's
just that light takes longer and longer
to reach us until there's no more light
from outside whoa
that proves it
is he a doctor of physics uh
that is evidential i like the idea that
we're in a black hole i think it might
be twisting too it looks like expanding
because we're it's bending it's bending
wow
all right let's uh let's grab some more
stuff here the wombolt says as a shane
myself who loves the oddities of cults
and witches would give my left hand to
work with shane
two shanes
we can only have one
we we would use the hand to create
another shane and then yeah
we
we're trying to find a writer to do the
smaller stories yeah so when shane's
doing the deeper investigations there's
day-to-day stuff like a ufo report comes
out right we need a basic the
congressional hearing they just had
exactly like that would have been a
great one i don't buy any of that
no but like getting a reporter not the
not the government stuff that they're
pushing getting a mysteries reporter to
talk about these stories just straight
objectively yeah yeah yeah you know
short they're shorter they're not you
know in-depth and then that person could
theoretically do the conspiracy talk
show with you guys oh yeah and you know
i had another idea for a show too was um
collins ghost story calling shows before
they exist there's a bunch of like coast
to coast like it's good that's gonna be
great those are fun those are fun super
fun so these are the things we want to
figure out it'd be really cool i love
when people call in and tell their
experiences yeah because there's so many
stories out there that are amazing i did
a road trip across the country once and
all we listened to the entire way was
peep calling ghost stories
and some of them are like come on come
on some of them are really cool though
and it's literally just someone being
like so i'm in my house
and you know the guy hung himself here
when i was in the door slams and i'm
just like oh what next what next it's
like the most nonsense
like it's meaningless none of it matters
but you just want to know what happens
but it's relatable right you know it's
like jerry spence you know the lawyer
the defense lawyer jerry spence guy
never lost a case he wrote books about
this you know he had a whole thing where
he said you know if you're if you're
gonna try a case about you know it's
it's you have to you have to put the
person in the car right if you're if
you're trying to case about a car crash
don't just tell the jury hey there was a
car crash and it happened on tuesday and
this when the road was slick and no
put them in the car give them the story
and make it relatable and that is
something that's going to be compelling
and pull somebody in so the fact that
and this is why paranormal um
activity was such a popular movie
because it's just what happens in your
house when you're asleep right
i want to say uh so puppets in politics
is how can one apply for mystery
reporter uh send an email to jobs at
timcast.com
send writing samples along with it and
any relevant information i don't
necessarily i don't personally care too
much about resumes i don't know what you
think shane resume is useless the
writing is what matters right yeah send
in some some writing samples and then
have a conversation and the reality is
the unfortunate thing is
a lot of people don't want jobs right
now
but of the jobs people want they really
want to work places like here in the
daily wire because you know we're
culture warriors we're you know trying
to do cool things we're trying to
challenge the machine
so it's almost like a lottery ticket we
get 10 000 plus emails every month or
something more and it's just not
possible to read every single one but uh
we'll start looking into it yeah and
we'll have shane writing samples would
be great send those and i i never look
at resume stuff and that's the one thing
we really got to launch too because
one of the like at first we wanted tales
from the inverted world to be more
interactive with the audience yeah but
we like ultimately discovered we have to
focus on the heavy hitting stuff like
you writing a book and then getting the
stories out
but i think the the the vod version will
be the long-form show hour-long
conversation oh yeah we definitely got
to do that
yeah i mean even if we did it once a
week definitely something we could get
people to sign up become members for
yeah and then
you know what the daily wire is doing
with their movies
tear on the prairie it's kind of obvious
right uh um what was the other movie
they did uh with the runway fight run
hide fight but there was the one
with the woman in the in the room
yeah locked up yeah one of the things
they're doing is they're buying movies
that they can afford to buy and they're
producing movies that are rather simple
but good story so tara on the prairie
it's look it's costume it's it's drama
but it's like in an open field so it's
relatively low budget to produce
but they make a good compelling story a
movie worth watching because you gotta
you gotta work with what you have we're
doing the same thing i'm hoping that in
five years the daily wire is bigger than
disney i'm hoping that we're as big as
the daily wire or actually bigger than
they are at the same time and that
there's going to be more companies like
ours who aren't going to be producing
garbage what crap i will say
what you do want
is preachy ideological content
however you don't want woke preachy
ideological content you want thing that
represents things that represent your
values an example is matt walsh made a
book called johnny the walrus it's
preachy it's got a message but it's a
message you like
so i i think that when people say like i
don't want politics in my tv show and
i'm like no that's not that's not the
case you want good values in your tv
shows and you want the substance of the
story
i don't like it when like orville makes
an episode that's so on the nose it's
like we get it the ladies trump
seriously come on add a little nuance
and a little metaphor to that
so you want it to not be nothing but
preach but you want your values
represented in it so that's what i'm
hoping to do and become a member at
timcast.com let's uh let's grab one more
gem r says did you see that uganda found
12 trillion us dollars worth of gold
deposits what's the odds the west will
suddenly be very concerned about human
rights in uganda
you heard it here first folks all right
everybody if you haven't already smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
it is maga month so follow us over at
tim tim cast irl on instagram or
wherever else follow me at tim cast
become a member at timcast.com celebrate
manga weekend which is this this weekend
right now we got the fourth so we got
friday night we got saturday we got
sunday and monday we are gonna be
fireworks hot dogs we're gonna be doing
all that good stuff i hope you guys have
a good weekend jack you want to shout
anything out yeah um look you guys know
where to follow me human events daily we
are hiring turning point usa is hiring
uh you can check that on on the site
also and not for myself to push out but
my wife is
the special guest on the podcast the
spillover this weekend she's telling her
story for the first time ever escaping
communism growing up in the soviet union
coming to america so you can find that
on podcast spill over and then we've
also got turning point usa sas coming up
end of july donald trump
ron desantis same stage maybe not the
same time but down in tampa florida
tpusa.com
use promo code poso all caps 25 off
awesome
i am uh really proud of this book and i
hope you guys go check it out the first
episode is up now on youtube apple
spotify
if you want to see witches pull demons
out of the thin air and skeletons
standing in the upright in the ground
waiting to shoot the devil dead
and just hear really interesting stories
about the war um i've completely changed
the way i view a lot of the things that
happened in the war and history in
general so please check that out tails
from the inverted world everywhere and
i'm shane cashman everywhere online
well ian crossland you guys know where
to find me i like how you said that you
know where to find me ian crossland.net
uh much love jack always great to see
you man i'm glad you came in you
[ __ ]
i'm gonna keep it family friendly
because i'm about to swear up and down
i love you guys i love you thank you so
much for coming i'll see you later thank
you guys all for tuning in for this wild
and crazy friday night really looking
forward to the fourth of july hope you
guys are too i hope you guys get out and
grill and have fun with your families
you guys can find me on twitter and
mines.com at sourpatches as well as
sourpatch let's stop me
maga month
we will see you all tuesday because this
is the opening weekend of manga month
with the 4th of july hot dogs burgers
grilling american flags then we'll be
back on tuesday we'll see you then
thanks for hanging out
you